okay
good morning everyone
I hope everybody enjoyed their uh little
reprieve from the committee for a couple
okay so we'll open up the public hearing
on Senate Bill 37 establishing committee
to study hospitality and tourism
education in New Hampshire and I have a
good morning Senator Ennis
good morning Mr chair good morning
members of the committee
uh
for the record Dan Ennis from Bradford
New Hampshire District Seven and I'm
here before you to introduce Senate bill
37. this is a a nice little simple Bill
Bill let me give you a little background
on it as you may know I've been in the
hospitality business myself here in the
state I'm still have an interest out of
state in the industry uh and I'm a
professor at UNH marketing is my primary
discipline but I'm in the department of
hospitality management and over the last
number of years we've witnessed a
general decline in interest in this
industry beginning in the high schools
following all the way through to the
community colleges as well as the
university system
that runs counter to our state's needs
as you know tourism travel and tourism
is a major part of our state's economy
as we're building the budget we look at
the rooms and meals tax it's a big deal
industry so some discussions over the
last several years it occurred to me
that you know we're not meeting the
demand
that the industry has for graduates
whether it's Community College or high
school or or the universities in fact
the estimates are from the New Hampshire
restaurants and Lodging Association that
the institutions are meeting about 10
percent of that demand
so the purpose of this commission is to
take a look at things and try to really
understand what's going on but more
importantly what we might be able to do
about that whether it's a public-private
partnership with industry or it's a
change in the way we're doing funding or
maybe something even simpler than that
that will encourage young people to take
a look at this industry it's a terrific
industry it's it's really doing well
it's growing very quickly right now
we'll hope that continues that's good
for the state and for workers so the
commission includes the usual menu of
senators and representatives but also
the president of the New Hampshire
restaurants and Lodging Association and
owner operator of a restaurant owner
operator of a hotel and representatives
from the New Hampshire community college
system and the university system of New
Hampshire as well as a representative
from CTE appointed by the Department of
Education so I think it'll be a good
commission that will help us to
understand the issue and really dig into
to it and ideally will give us some
direction on where to go from here I'm
happy to take any questions if there are
any
representative Burroughs
yes thank you for taking my question
um do you envision that this commission
will also study where to house these
these folks that's a really interesting
question and last week I actually went
to the New London Hospital to hear about
the project that's being done there
which should help the hospital with some
of their staffing issues I don't see why
that couldn't be considered and we know
in the Seacoast in particular that's a
major issue affordable housing is is in
short supply and while the industry has
raised the wages significantly in the
last number of years
um it's hard it's hard for anyone to
afford to live in the Seacoast at this
point so I'm sure that will be a
consideration yes
for the question because again in my
area there's no housing there's just no
housing I'm in the North Country though
the good news is we have five new Mega
hotels coming in and they could stay
there yeah if um they got jobs yeah and
you know you see with a lot of resort
hotels and that sort of thing they will
put housing in for their employees
um and Glacier Park is one of my
favorite places on Earth and I'm always
amazed at the number of people who
descend on that Park and loop there
um in seasonal housing so there are
solutions that can work and and again
maybe that's the public private
partnership sort of activity similar to
what we're seeing in New London yes
thank you for the question
the only questions yeah representative
Mr chairman thank you Senator Ennis for
coming to see us uh as the prime sponsor
on this bill and as it sets up the
number of folks who are going to be on
it says two members of the Senate
appointed by the president are you
willing to be one of those members of
course thank you yes
representative
I ask because
um I represent Hollis in Brooklyn we
have a lot of Agriculture there our
hospitality industries inextricably
linked with that element and I wondered
because agritourism is probably one of
the biggest things I'm trying to expand
as a culinarian of 40 years in the state
and wondered if you hadn't considered
that part of that might cover that
because people being interested in much
like they do in Europe and in Italy that
model we could identify here and do as
well much like many of the institutions
and farms in my in my district I think
that's a fantastic question and believe
it or not
um I have 154 Acre Farm in Bradford and
that's one of the things that we've been
thinking about we're not doing it right
now it's chickens goats and cows but
people like those things and I think
agriculture in this state is Hard
Scrabble you've got to be creative in
how you generate revenue and I think
this is one of the great ways to go as
well as Farm to Table and smoothing that
process and you'll see a bill on that so
somebody will later yes but thank you I
I think we definitely should take a look
at that particularly for the more rural
parts of our state which is entirely my
district so yes thank you representative
uh yes
thank you for taking my questions why a
commission why can
um
why do we need a commission can you know
you and others come together maybe
monthly to you know form a coalition
instead of a commission I say that
because
representative petusic is on a
commission to study commissions or to
get rid of commissions you know it's not
the way to we really don't want to be
voting on new commissions right now
it's a good idea yeah well that vote on
the idea uh but but honestly I think
that commissions are something that I
tried not to do but in this case I think
we need a good hard look at it and we
really need significant input from
industry in a formalized structure to
keep people on track to do it the
Coalition idea is a good one but you
know the Coalition doesn't have
deadlines it doesn't have a formal
process and I I think
it probably would have a little less
credibility as well and I'm hoping this
gives us something that we can really
work with to build a better situation
representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair
I'm just focusing in uh representative
batusic pointed out the Sunset date
which is November 1st yes
2023 yes and the report is due by then
yes do you think that date's realistic
yes
so in my experience it takes the
governor a little while
to sign the bill and then appoint
commission members they have to do a
search yeah
um and and that might not happen until
maybe uh September October
and this is November 1st that makes
November problematic
um you might have one or two meetings uh
before that deadline so
um I'm perfectly amenable to a later
date if the committee thinks that's
reasonable yes thank you for that that's
a very important point I appreciate it
yeah yeah I was going to wait to say
anything but uh we our experiences when
you have all these different people need
to be appointed there's a time delay
yeah I've been away for a while I
sometimes forget these things so so
maybe you're kind of jumping the gun on
that uh expiration date I'm anxious I
guess uh usually something like this
that the report that comes out is uh
continuing the commission for another
two years exactly yeah we're not I don't
want to do we don't want to see that we
want to get it done and and get
something to happen right yes and that's
why deadlines are important but at the
same time you know getting people
together and I think you might have a
timing problem yes thank you okay rivers
and feel
uh looking at the uh work for the
commission under the commission shall
examine existing hospitality and tourism
programs and community colleges and
universities Statewide including
curriculum and enrollment Trends I'm
assuming that the intent here is for the
committee to examine hospitality and
tourism programs within community
colleges and universities Statewide
instead of giving the community the
commission uh broad-ranging fishing
expedition to go within universities and
uh colleges Statewide is that correct
that's correct as a follow-up would you
then be amenable to changing the words
uh the wording examine existing
hospitality and tourism programs within
community colleges and universities
Statewide to prevent the commission from
having the option of taking examine
examination of the UNH physics program
for example that would be just fine yes
my knowledge of physics is much less
than Hospitality might as well yes thank
you
covered this but uh is there any if I
recall Cornell has a a major in uh
basically hoteling Hospitality do we
have any such thing in this state
currently
I will be discussing this with my
department chair when I get back yes the
University of New Hampshire has a
department of hotels and Hospitality
management it's the second oldest
program in the country second only to
Cornell
so yes we do and it's a strong
well-respected program
um and the community colleges has have
some terrific programs in culinary and
other areas as well so yes we have it
here it needs to be stronger and better
and that's part of what this is about
yes thank you for that question that
that gives me some insight that in all
seriousness I'm taking back to UNH we
have to do a better job publicizing to
our Market is better than what we're
doing yes thank you and as I said
nothing is easy
but it's always good okay we're all set
thank you very much all right thank you
I appreciate it greatly
good morning uh Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Henry vayu and I'm here on behalf of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association
um I think Senator Innis did a good job
of explaining
uh why the bill is before you
um
under the bill uh nhlra the lodging
Restaurant Association would have a seat
uh as an association and then two
members uh which well a restaurant or
and a hotelier
um and so we support the bill
um representative burles to your point
about the housing I was talking with uh
one of the uh Hotel years up uh in the
uh North Country uh earlier this year
and was asking them how things are going
and how's you know Finding staff and he
said Henry he said I'm now in the
property management business because
he's having to buy up lodging to house
uh so uh he thought he was getting in
the you know the hotel business and now
he's having to to Branch out and find
places for uh staff that you know
otherwise
um he can't stop his place so because
they can't afford either they can't find
places to live or it's too expensive so
but we uh we support the bill I'd be
no questions okay thank you I have one
more card here Sebastian
uh
tweets Fuentes sorry mine is my
handwriting was a little well I should
try to emphasize people we don't need
your autograph we just need to there we
go that's your name right uh well good
morning Mr chairman the members of the
committee uh my name is Sebastian
Fuentes I'm the movement politics
director of horizon democracy of New
Hampshire but I'm here under a different
title uh I used to be a Hospitality
worker for the last 17 years of my life
I work in the North Country at Diamond
Washington hotel at Breton woods and I
also work at the mountain view grand up
in Whitefield New Hampshire both
properties have um had a um uh
cooperation between local high schools
and also colleges up north uh the one
Mountain Regional High School with the
White Mountain uh the Mountain View
Grand Resort and Spa in the Mount
Washington hotel Omni property now with
the Granite State College in the way
Mountain Community College which they
have a culinary apprenticeship program
they have a hotel management program and
also for the the ski industry we have a
ski Management program which is
definitely extremely important for us uh
just going back to the question by
representative Burris about housing you
know at the omniberton woods there's a
different definitely an issue with that
uh you know we we have to have to house
a lot of international workers to come
here on the J-1 Visa program too and
sometimes we only have a spot to put
them you know we have to rent literally
hotels motels down in Twin Mountain to
be able to to host them but we also need
that Workforce because otherwise the
scariest chemical function is key leaf
cannot go up you know so it's definitely
a Critic a Critic issue we have up there
um employee retention the I think
and to see how how strong and severe
that is I interview so many people for
the last 17 years to be able to come to
work for us and some of those issues
that they have is you know housing
education uh sometimes Child Care
coverage you know for those workers that
want to come work at a hotel you know
and and sometimes diversity you know the
North country is not really one of the
most diverse areas in in the whole state
so that can be a little bit of an issue
um and something for the off the Record
too to share with you all uh that while
um that we're Mountain Regional High
School just recently got a regional
award uh they were Regional Champions on
Hospitality Management program so uh
they do pretty good they have a pretty
good program over there uh and I think
this study alone will give us will give
us the right amount of information to to
see where we can we can do better we can
we can improve and what should continue
so um yeah um I just want to give you my
perspective as a former Hospitality
worker but I know this this is something
that I definitely support and I hope you
oh take any questions if you have
anything guess we're all set oh we do
representative Ammon thank you Mr chair
you mentioned the lack of diversity in
the White Mountains could you explain
what you mean by that it's just not you
know if you if you live in uh for
example I interview people that lived in
uh in Boston to come and work in a
management uh titles up in the north
country or New York you know because we
do hiring uh fairs down there to get
management here and when they come
upstairs like they don't see a lot of
things that they can do on the free time
you know so sometimes that's
discouraging for them you know uh you
know uh
the North country is is small
communities it's not like if you live in
Manchester or concrete for example you
know that you see a little bit more you
know restaurants for example or uh
different menus or you know or you know
activities that you can do so sometimes
that's a little uh you know puts a
little you know a negative thought on
your head like you know what this this
area is not really welcoming when it
actually is the opposite uh you know we
we thrive on tourism we love people
coming to the North Country to visit us
uh and it's you know as you know it's a
beautiful spot one of the most beautiful
okay
thank you very much thank you so much uh
having no more cards on Senate Bill 37
and this bill will go to the business
foreign
okay
okay we'll open up the public Hearing in
Senate Bill 64 and uh the prime sponsor
is not here today so we have Grant Bossy
he's yeah it's from the prime sponsor
this is the Senate bill yeah
thank you Mr chairman uh Senator Gannon
sends his regards he's been moved into
rehab and he hopes to be back at the
state house uh shortly
um good morning to the entire Commerce
Committee I am Grant bossy from the New
Hampshire Senate here to introduce
Senate bill 64. on behalf of Senator
Gannon the prime sponsor this bill would
establish a committee to study
resident-owned Manufacturing Housing
disputes as well as possible oversight
of them last session the Senate heard
that residents in these communities have
no mechanism to resolve complaints
against their boards to develop a
dispute resolution process this study
committee would be tasked with gathering
information from residents and other
stakeholders resident-owned communities
rocs are multi-million dollar
Investments which are paid for by their
residents thus this study committee
would also examine if there were an
appropriate regulatory oversight
mechanism that could be established the
Senate approved SB 64 on the consent
calendar Senator Gannon thanks you for
your consideration and support of SB 64.
thank you very much
thank you
what's that oh yeah your written
testimony would be great to have in the
fine
I'm representative Fred plett uh my I
usually hang out ways and means it's
nice to visit Commerce and consumer
affairs I am a resident of medville
Cooperative in Goffstown it's a 301 home
park we've been a rock resident owned
communities for about 16 years I've been
treasurer for the last two years on the
board I'm not currently on the board
this is very important because there is
no mechanism for Resident owned
community members to complain if the
board's abusing the powers or or a
member of the board is abusing his or
her powers
or they're not following bylaws or
whatever and right now there isn't there
is a committee there is a committee it's
uh it's dominated by investor own
interests the owners of investor own and
even there that if it's investor on
maybe there should be some non-owner
representation but it it does not serve
the resident-owned communities well at
all and priority in room knows it exists
so so there aren't that many complaints
because they don't know what exists
that's it I'll be happy to take
questions uh but I'm I'm personally have
been involved you know people are people
there are conflicts we've worked them
out so far but uh if it had gone much
further I'd have file the complaint
thank you
we have questions representative billow
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um is there an attorney that works with
your board yes
very much so and and follow-ups would he
or she be
um there to assist you with your needs
absolutely it does all the time
but still having a board that represents
resident owned members is uh uh uh so
that they understand the environment is
very helpful for the attorney to appeal
okay thanks
representative petusic thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question questions I have two
questions uh first question would be uh
inasmuch as there are three members in
the Senate and three members of the
house and you're a co-sponsor would you
be willing to serve on this board
absolutely thank you the second question
you're on record
thank you representative also on line 25
on on the page it says order before
November 1 of 2023 I realize this is
probably unrealistic would you be
willing to go out to 2024 absolutely
thank you
it representative spear
I read on the reports thank you very
much
reports that the Senate put together for
this bill and
it seems like there's real issues here I
mean no doubt about that
but I wonder why lawsuits and things
like that haven't been tried or have
they been tried and they don't work or
lawsuits yeah lawsuits against the
boards
um I can't don't have any experience so
we've had some issues within medville uh
uh but I wouldn't characterize any of
his lawsuits we've had to take a member
to to expel evict and process like that
but there's never been no lawsuits
against the board to date
the the boards are elected they are
elected so why haven't you voted them
out
um
that's a very long process uh let's say
um the the our bylaws say that the
members elect the board members and uh
if the board is unhappy with a
particular member say a president as
example
uh they can write a letter asking that
person to resign but they can't kick the
member off that has to go to a special
member meeting which is a five thousand
dollar expense and has to be set up and
the odds of anything happening are dicey
because the member can be spreading
misinformation
so it's not an easy process but it's
still an election every year right we
have an election every year so
theoretically if everybody in that
Community agrees that the board members
are being irresponsible
why haven't they voted them out
um
that hasn't happened to date but it
could very well happen uh this this but
I guess it rather than wait once a year
if there's a if there's an issue that
the board can appeal you can appeal to
an independent board and get results
that's better
Okay the reason I go this question I
realize you have some questions but
um the Commerce Committee has oversight
over condos yes and homeowners
associations yes
um is Iraq any different than those it's
only a difference is they were owned by
the members I own one 301st of that Park
uh and so uh and uh I'm represented by
the board and the the board generally
functions well but there may be a member
who two or two who doesn't function well
I'll just leave it there right so but
over the years this committee has often
seen
uh legislation related to homeowners
association should try to I guess
arbitrate
problems within a community yes and
we've always decided not to go forward
with that because at the end of the day
you're you're a private Community you
have your ownership you have it's yours
and and and the feeling that the state
should have an arbitrator or a court a
judge or something they come in and
intervene with a community with a with a
with a homeowners association's you know
uh
disputes with each other uh has always
seemed inappropriate so why why would
this be any different than I mean yes we
can go forward with the commission but
if if the outcome that people are
looking for is the state's going to have
some kind of referee over what's going
on inside a community or trying to do
something
um this committee has never passed
anything like that then I ask you to
reconsider because it's a valuable tool
uh that it can happen much more often
than once a year and uh it can can take
a dispassionate
input
from from several sources that make up
its mind uh in an annual meeting there's
a lot going on on other than the
election of members so I ask you to
reconsider that uh and it got so strong
support from the Senate the other body
and I think it's a worthwhile tool
fair enough eating Beth did
representative brazili
okay all right representative Burroughs
thank you for taking my question
um what's the process for changing your
bylaws
uh both of the members
uh we we the the uh we we had proposed
several bylaw changes at our last annual
meeting uh the board vets them with the
attorney we decide whether or not to go
forward then we bring them to the
members to vote at the annual meeting
and we do that it did that
and rules as well for the question so if
you can if you have the members could
change the bylaws why can't you change
the process you know you mentioned the
five thousand dollar fee can you change
the process to make it easier
um to do what you want to do rather than
have a commission
uh you're talking with 301 299 members
there's two who are owned by the
previous owner that's 299 members
getting a quorum is not easy first of
all second uh it is uh it's easy it's uh
to uh
to uh mislead people uh with uh with uh
false charges rumors flying around I've
had several flying around about me and I
just addressed them head on so this is
not true but this stuff happens and and
so it may not get a fair hearing at a
meeting like that especially with a lot
representative action hi
hi you know my concern these things the
rocks and I'm familiar with them from my
business are actually condos it's a you
have an undivided
130 whatever percent interest in this
common property
so because they're mobile homes they've
received some
and they're mostly where you mostly the
you got Department of Agriculture
financing to buy it off of the former
owner oh that's a common scenario but my
concern here is you're when you go down
this road you're going to be getting
involved with mediating homeowners
disputes in Condominiums and
cooperatives and
I just I get it that it's hard to sort
things out at town meeting or your
community meeting
we all have that in our towns I mean
I sometimes I think that's just the
nature of the Beast
uh but I have so I have reservations is
there a question here it's not my
question this is a would you am I
missing something yeah
we got our financing 15 years ago 16
years ago for a Citizens Bank and New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund and I
refinanced the New Hampshire Community
Loan Fund last year with a Bellwether
and saved a bunch of interest in the
process but uh the the so and I we are
not mobile homes
we're manufactured housing and there's a
big difference and so to uh it's to call
a owner of a manufactured house say is
owning a mobile or she is owning a
mobile home that's a step down my
apology no doubt it doesn't move yeah it
does not move
okay yes representative
so I just want to be clear here that in
response to
um like my colleague's question
I believe I heard you say that it would
be difficult to get the membership
together in order to vote to change the
bylaws
even though each all of them have a
vested interest in this and that uh they
would be subject to misinformation and
disinformation
if that if if what I heard is correct
then is it also correct that what I'm
hearing from you is that you prefer a
different process because of the
inconvenience and the likelihood of some
messiness and having the membership make
the decision and if in fact that is what
you're saying can you cite examples
where in fact that has happened that
there have been examples of
misinformation disinformation and not
being able to get enough people to come
to a meeting in order to make changes uh
how many examples can you get I have one
on top of my mind but it won't speak to
it because it's it's raw and it's recent
and it involves people so I just will
refrain from answering the question but
it exists
follow okay you don't want me to
this is only a one-way Street Mr
chairman
okay representative
thank you Mr chair
um I won't ask you about that situation
either a question about the bill I
realize you're not the prime sponsor but
you are a sponsor yes on uh line 18. I
wonder if you could expand on the
statement it says that the commission
would solicit testimony from any person
or organization with relevant
information or expertise could you give
us an idea of what kind of testimony and
from which organizations from which
persons you would be soliciting boards
and members of Resident owned
communities including medville where I
live but several others and they may be
able to come up with examples they're
not willing to speak to in public right
here
okay
representative Priscilla you have a
question now thank you I'm I'm still
trying to figure out why
if it operates similar to a condo
association why can't you create your
own dispute resolution process and
oversight committee outside of the board
so if there are these I mean I get it
right A lot of people living in a small
community there are disputes but if it's
if it's so egregious I would imagine
that the membership would want to create
their own board so they have
self-governing ability rather than I I
can't even imagine what type of
legislation would be proposed out of the
committee
um let's say it may not be distant
enough from the problem
it may be involved very personalities
that that uh
would lead to further dispute and
sometimes you need something a step or
two or away
to review it with some dispassionate
eyes
representing calabrum
I think what you're talking about is
having mediation and hiring attorneys to
be able to have that kind of mediation
and that could be part of the bylaws yes
but a board to go to with that mediation
yes thank you
representative spear thank you in
answering representative Terry's
question
I
yes that's you
if you go on the docket and look at the
Senate report a lot of the examples that
you're looking for have been written up
and they're in there so you can find
some information about what a lot of
details about what some of the problems
are
I wasn't are we gonna have a
conversation here in the committee no
would you believe you should later we
don't need to take up the Public's time
I'll speak with you later okay
I think we're all set thank you thank
you
okay so we'll pick up where we left off
good morning and welcome back to the
Commerce Committee
good morning Mr chair and committee
members my name is Louise Rideout and I
do remember you from last year
thank you for hearing my testimony today
I'm from Bayview Crossing Cooperative
Allenstown New Hampshire
and I support Senate bill 64.
the goal of this bill is to develop a
dispute resolution program at no expense
to the state
and determine if there is appropriate
oversight of resident-owned communities
we have been working with many other
resident owned communities over the past
few years to address this issue and have
been opposed by the Community Loan Fund
every step of the way
why would anybody oppose this bill it
does no harm
we purchase app hack over three years
ago
since then we have had three different
sets of board of directors we have
experienced board members not following
our bylaws and not applying the rules
consistently to every resident
Nara park is in financial ruin this is
not unique to our community
neighbor governing neighbor has been a
disaster
why is oversight needed
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund is
a lender and because they are non-profit
they are not regulated by any federal
estate agencies like other lenders
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund
lends money to Residents so they can
purchase the epox at high interest
the Community Loan Fund stands up the
park and then walks away leaving
residents with no experience running a
multi-million dollar Corporation
there needs to be more transparency and
guidance for residents when considering
a plan to purchase a park
when we purchased our pack we had no
idea that the contract included a
provision
in which we would have to make interest
only payments on a 4.9 million dollar
loan to the Community Loan Fund
we are also not permitted to sell our
pack for 10 years
if we do decide to sell our pack the
funds go to Community Loan Fund or
another non-profit so if we were to make
any type of um
profit on we can't make a profit because
we are labeled not for profit and that
most of the members when voted
the 68 that voted for it and I wasn't in
I wasn't one of the 68 but we were not
told at that time we were not-for-profit
every single resident pays the mortgage
through the allotment even if they
didn't want to purchase the pack yet we
still don't truly own OPAC
we pay Community Loan funds seven
thousand dollars annually for technical
assistance
in testimony last week it was referred
to twenty thousand hours
the Community Loan Fund gave will we pay
for it about two years ago we became
aware that there were funds missing from
our Park
a substantial amount of money the New
Hampshire Community loans fund response
was to treat this as water under the
bridge and directed us to start with a
clean slate the following year
this guidance was not in the fiduciary
interest of our community
we fought for over two years for a
forensic audit and were finally
successful after the Attorney General's
office directed The Community Loan Fund
to do so
based on the audit that it's being done
right now the forensic got it it was
determined and actually
the Community Loan Fund person last week
publicly said that there was this
missing money significant amount of
missing money in response the Community
Loan Fund directed our board to have our
community vote on whether or not to
report the missing funds to the
authorities
based on testimony provided by the New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund
we discovered that funds were diverted
from a bank account by a board member
please understand not all residents and
Resident owned communities wanted to
purchase the packs might be in one of
them it does not take a majority of
residents to to vote to purchase a Pac
in our pack we have 287 units but only
68 people voted to purchase the puck
one would think that if New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund had a larger base of
support to purchase the puck you
wouldn't have these problems I probably
wouldn't be here today asking for this
bill
the Community Loan Fund has amassed a
Fortune over the years if the New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund truly
supports its residents it should assist
us in developing a dispute resolution
resolution program for residents in
rocks at no cost to the state we're not
ask we're not Beggars asking you guys to
fund things that we don't need
we just need some help right now
since the Community Loan Fund benefits
from residents purchasing their parks I
respectfully request that this committee
supports Senate bill 64. I believe that
passing this bill will give many co-ops
hope that serious issues will have an
opportunity for resolution
if you if you were a homeowner in the
situation right now that apoc is in you
would definitely say is there any kind
of help that we can get we are not
Beggars we're not saying oh you have to
fund this you have to fund that we're
just asking for maybe an oversight maybe
people who aren't right in the sick of
it to look I was a federal employee for
18 years and I went to many mediations
with other employees
and usually the government would send
somebody in from the outside
and that person would listen to both
sides and then come up with some
suggestions and then and I being
participating in that was really helpful
and I could see how great it was and if
you have somebody already willing to
volunteer to help
that isn't going to be hand-picked by
Community Loan Fund it's it's a
beginning can you give us a chance
that's all we're asking for thank you
representative Sullivan
he's taking my my uh my question so
would you mind explaining how it is that
you guys or that the community that a
minority could decide to sell the park
or buy the park rather
you said I think it would you say like
67 out of over 200 people that's all it
took so that's less than 50 that seems
odd to me can you explain how that
process works I I'm gonna be honest like
I was I bought my home in 2018 October
2018. two weeks after I bought it I got
the packet that it was being sold and I
went to many many meetings about the
co-op and nothing was really explained
to us but at that time it was the
majority of the people who showed up at
the meeting not the majority of the
homeowners so that was the problem that
it was they were just looking for a
quorum at the meeting
so not everybody was informed and not
everybody attended the meetings Sarah
for the question you mean choir so what
you're saying is
um it's just whoever showed up to that
meeting it's not necessarily like
everybody has to vote it's just whoever
she's up to a specific meeting it's not
even like a necessarily an election day
it's you have to show up for it or yeah
it was just excuse me it was to show up
but we also had to have that member fee
paid to be able to vote and and the
Senate Bill 210 if you look into that
that will show you how a lot of these
issues
have been helped help the residents make
better decisions when the attackers up
for sale so Senate Bill 210 really kind
of laid the ground work for a lot of
this
thank you thank you all right
representative McAleer is next uh thank
you Mr chairman I've got two questions
if I may
um have you looked at any sort of model
legislation that other states might have
on this issue has anybody explored that
I at this time I I haven't looked into
it I'm not really sure
you know
I have a lot of family responsibilities
right now so I I do as much as I can do
but if you could suggest things I would
be happy to look into other states I
mean we're we're for any type of help we
can get so if it's something that you
can suggest
my number will be on here you can call
for the question main choir
unfortunately I don't have any
suggestions yet but I may come up but
the other thing that concerns me it
sounds like that one of your board
members embezzled money was there no
insurance to cover that uh that event I
would think that the the board should
have had some sort of insurance that
would have covered that and I'm very
shocked that they that maybe there isn't
and and I'm also shocked if this guy
hasn't if you haven't sent the
authorities after him thank you
with not to my knowledge that there's
any insurance to cover any type of
wrongdoing embezzlement or
misappropriation of funds but for almost
two years now I've been asking at every
meeting what's going on what's going on
and if you could tell me the last part
of the question I'm sorry I'm getting
old I forgot the last part of that about
well have you actually notified the
authorities about this
what we're doing right now is a forensic
audit is being done and it's under the
direction Community Loan Fund which kind
of can is we're in default right now too
and this is another thing we are in a
non-monetary default and everybody
really needs to understand what it means
we are paying our loans
but Community Loan Fund has put us in a
non-monetary default for almost a year
and a half now with no end in sight we
get promise that we're going to come out
if we get these paperwork done correctly
or if the board is okay and you know
management company is being treated
fairly but what about us being treated
fairly so
we we're in the dock to be honest with
you we're in the dark are they going to
pursue and I asked Mr claspy of
Community Loan Fund over a year ago what
happens if there's any wrongdoing and he
said it could be prosecution restitution
jail time and then I asked him if any
other co-op had they dealt with anything
like that he said yes but he wouldn't
elaborate for me so that I put that
information out over a year ago to the
family Loan Fund and this is we're in
the dock this is forensic audit that we
are paying for we're paying for they
took money from our funds without us
even voting for because we're in default
so they can seem to be able to
run everything so this is what we're up
against so what we I'm sorry I wish I
had more information I want the
information to believe me
thank you okay uh representative
Burroughs and then representative
um thank you for taking my question I'm
going to go back to my question about
the bylaws and relate it to what
representative Sullivan said you know
because you you mentioned this meeting
where the bylaw said it was a majority
of members present and would you believe
that it sounds like you're you haven't
gotten good advice legal advice in terms
of the bylaws
um in in terms of insurance so I'm
wondering if if um would you think that
rather than a committee that there needs
to be some kind of resource for
communities like yours to advise so that
you don't have to hire a 700 an hour
attorney
I think that this where we are right now
I think we need both
I think to say try to go and do it on
your own it's kind of hot and look at
the pr look at the money we have been
paying seven thousand dollars a year to
Community Loan Fund for technical
support and our temp our first bylog
templates were from them
so if they haven't been changed and
revised
it's maybe it's time to do a lot of that
maybe it is time but like you said we
really can't afford an attorney
we already have a Pac attorney that
works for many many
Loan Fund aerosis rocks
but I think both would be right now is
what we need if we can get
away from one of them that'd be great
like I said when not Vegas asking for
representative
do you know if you're uh organization is
incorporated as an Corporation or as an
LLC or as a partnership I was told that
we are we have you Crossing Cooperative
Cooperative Incorporated
so I was told we are Incorporated
as a as a follow-up
for the question
if if you were a corporation then how
does why is it and you may not know this
that the remedy doesn't follow then
under the corporations act and a breach
of fiduciary duty
I agree with you I would love to find
out that when I asked I sent an email to
somebody at Community Loan Fund
asking to explain more what's going on
and zero response so we do need more
knowledge absolutely correct we need to
know what we got into we need we need to
know how to run a corporation we have a
two million dollar corporate two million
dollars a year we take in we have 21
million dollars worth of loans we
absolutely need more more direction
thank you very much
infection
hi so this is a hearing on a bill to
create a committee it and it sounds to
me which which then might or might not
so given that this committee was created
and what would the legislation be that
you would Envision coming out of it what
is it that you think
the state should be doing to interfere
in the operations of a private
Corporation well this is what is when I
heard about this it was being a study
I didn't really
for me personally I didn't want it to be
legislatures making new laws about
everything but more of a study that can
bring us where we need to be so we don't
need laws about everything that's going
on so this is what we're just asking for
a little bit of help right now
a steady help of like how we can get to
a better place but to to ask
legislators to enact things for us
if we don't have to get the a study
might resolve a lot of the things that
are going on like we might we might get
enough information
anyone getting enough information to
direct us in the right past we have to
don't to go
I I don't think that's what this bill
does
just so you're clear well I could be
wrong but it's it's would you believe
would you believe this is a bill to
create a committee to study the
operations on a broad basis of these
rocks right this is not going to be a
study on how the money's handled between
your Treasurer and president and your
Co-op oh I understand okay so it's
anything that this does
is at least a year away probably two and
is far more General than anything you're
discussing I mean I think we all get it
that your park has a particular problem
but this bill that we're discussing
unless you if you could explain to me so
representative just so you know we had
legislation last year and which he
testified and we have addressed some of
those issues okay and so this this is
just a carryover from that that previous
discussion all right so
representative Gibbs uh thank you Mr
chairman
um just follow up on the question about
reporting this problem to the
authorities
um you said that the forensic audit had
been ordered by the Attorney General's
office have you actually spoken with
anyone in the Consumer Protection Bureau
in the Attorney General's office and if
you have what did they say
I've made many phone calls and everybody
wants you to go to the consumer affairs
and that is not helping us at all so
they said they handle fraud they handle
things like that
but you also have to understand as a as
a member
I'm not privy to the forensic audit yet
and I and I sent an email asking when
the members when it's finished when are
we going to get the information you
can't just call people without the proof
we need the proof we need to be able to
bring something to them for them to do
anything because the rest of it I mean I
could call anybody and say Hey you know
this is going on we need the actual
proof and that is the question I asked
Community Loan Fund a week and a half
ago which I haven't yet to receive a
response is are the members going to be
able to get a copy of this forensic
audit so we can go to the consumer
affairs we can go go to the other things
that we need to go to we don't have
proof yet
thank you very much thank you okay uh
could you provide your testimony for the
yeah okay
so um since the new Community Loan Fund
got dragged into this you know two of
you guys want to come up and
explain
Your Role or lack of role in this
that's also
Lavon
Aaron
and uh for the committee's
recommendation
um it did happen before I was here that
uh the committee Loan Fund was created
uh a for the purpose of of allowing uh
manufactured housing parks that were
privately owned to then be owned by the
residents rather than having it sold to
another independent
um it turns out that most of these Parks
do not have leases and so they were very
vulnerable to that one owner and raising
and lower in terms of raising leases and
costs and benefits so in the wisdom of
the legislature that was 40 years ago
and I don't even think it was it was not
Commerce because Congress didn't do
condo bills back then so if uh in the
wisdom of the legislature they created
this entity that helps Finance for
communities for the people in a uh a
and good morning to Chairman hunt and
the members of the House Commerce
Committee my name is Tara Reardon I work
for the New Hampshire Community Loan
Fund which is a non-profit Community
Development Finance Institute whose
mission is to serve citizens of the
State of New Hampshire who otherwise
couldn't access Capital by that I mean
people that other people won't lend
money to highly unlikely
I provided you with our annual report so
you can read about our work our program
and the success of our borrowers there's
some great stories in there the oldest
and largest program of the Community
Loan Fund as chairman hunt just said is
the rock NH program Rock stands for
Resident owned communities and thanks to
a forward-thinking legislature back in
the 1980s it created not only the
opportunity to purchase but also divined
manufactured housing as real estate
which isn't necessarily common across
the United States there's a uniform law
commission that's come up with that law
but hasn't been widely adopted
the opportunity to purchase was created
because when you own your own home on
leased land it is uh highly unlikely
that you control the future of your
housing the land can be sold you can be
given 18 months notice to move your home
you're at the whim of a of another
investor and uh in fact we've had Park
closures here in New Hampshire where
people have had to walk away from their
homes as chairman hunt said before these
homes don't move
um sometimes it's a negotiated sale
where residents buy their communities
but oftentimes it's this opportunity to
purchase law and they have to pay the
exact same price an investor is going to
pay for that under the same terms close
in the same amount of time so the park
owner is uh comes out whole
we assist residents who are in that
situation by helping them form a co-op
it's a consumer Co-op under RSA 301a is
the entity that they form
and we've we help them Finance it along
with banks as you heard representative
let's say Citizens Bank is a uh is an
oftentimes a financer and will take the
hold the second mortgage in that case
and we also provide technical assistance
as you heard about 20 000 hours of
technical assistance and some of the
people that are here with me today are
the folks that go out to those
communities all week all weekend to help
out communities particularly new
communities learn the ropes bear view
that you've heard from this morning has
had over 7 200 hours of technical
assistance since 2019 when they were
formed sometimes that's because a new
board comes in they have had three
totally new boards in their short
existence
so in addition to that we help them do
infrastructure projects we've leveraged
about 64 million dollars worth of
infrastructure funding mostly USDA Rd
money as was alluded to before not not
likely used for purchases but is used to
improve the communities
so now there's 145 rocks in the state of
New Hampshire there's four more in
process right now they contain about 9
000 households and that's nine thousand
households who aren't worried anymore
about whether the land is going to be
sold out from under their home and
they're going to have to walk away from
it
and as you can imagine with 9 000
households issues arise sometimes and
those are going to arise I want to make
it clear whether that's an
investor-owned park or a resident owned
Park you'll hear in a minute from some
testimony from an investor-owned
resident and in the Senate hearing
compelling testimony from a resident and
an investor on Park who
had her water shut off periodically
without any notice when she was getting
ready for work and and things like that
it's in the it's uh nicely captured in
the Senate report so the issues arise
for a couple of reasons uh either about
the bylaws and the rules whether those
are working for the community whether
they're being enforced fairly or whether
those rules are even reasonable and if
you look back through the the
um list of the published opinions that
the manufactured housing board has heard
over the years A lot of times it's the
reasonable enforcement of a rule or the
reasonableness of a rule that's the
subject matter there those are things
that we deal with with communities all
the time and they do every Community has
an attorney if they're going to change
bylaws they propose a draft and run it
by their attorney to make sure it's
still within the law
and then there are people issues and the
people issues we can't control we're
we're not referees we're not babysitters
we're not
um you know
conflict resolution people we provide
technical assistance on the running of a
community and I'm not sure we can
legislate a solution to the people
issues that happen but but they are
widened wide-ranging
so we will work as we can with rules and
bylaws membership meetings making sure
that they're noticed so people know when
they are making sure agendas go out so
people can attend meetings uh there's a
lot of information given out at meetings
that people don't hear because they
don't they don't attend the meetings and
it's like any small town hall meeting or
democracy the world is run by those that
show up and in the case of deciding to
become a rock membership meetings do
have quorums but once they've met the
Quorum it's those that are present that
actually vote
on how that Community is run and who's
elected to those boards which I think
has come up as an issue before
so the only
um the only place the investor had a
chance to uh turn not to their board
what was to the manufactured housing
board that existed under the office of
oplc until hb2 it existed there is a
bill alive right now SB 203 that
executive departments and administration
heard the other day that revised the
manufactured housing board that's
currently run by the state made it a
smaller number of members more efficient
and that was introduced prior to knowing
that the governor was going to
reorganize oplc but it exists and it
works now and it works for Resident
owned communities and investor-owned
communities and it is the perfect
template or model for exactly what we're
talking about here a dispute resolution
with people who know the business of
living in Iraq or owning a an
investor-owned community
and the bill contemplates adding
somebody from housing action New
Hampshire somebody with expertise in
housing in order to round out that
five-person board but investor-owned
communities need to be part of this
conversation you've heard about Iraq and
and you've done some problem solving
already you have elections you can
change your bylaws people and investor
owned communities don't have any of
those possibilities they don't get to
change their leadership they don't get
to change their bylaws or their rules
they have no say in that so it's really
important that anything that's created
as a dispute resolution also include the
residents that live in investor owned
communities SB 203 as it stands right
now is a really great bill over in Edna
Senator Carson and Senator Perkins
Qualcomm made some great
additions to that bill that makes it
better and if in fact you choose to
create a study committee I would hope
that we would consider the elements that
are in SB 203 and certainly where
opposed to the study committee right now
because it doesn't include the investor
owned um
residence as well who really are in a
far worse position than the resident on
communities my colleague Aaron has a
letter from a woman in an investor-owned
Community I would be happy to answer
questions or be a resource for the
committee
great thank you my name is
representative spear
thank you I went online and I looked at
the um the board that we're talking
about the
could you tell me the name of it board
of manufactured houses second one the
board of manufactured housing and I
looked at what their Charter was
and it didn't appear that it would have
anything to do with
stepping in between a community and the
rules that have been set up in other
words if if a community is not if a uh
board I guess of the community is not
following the rules they don't really
have anything to do with that they only
help when you establish the rules
but they don't help any Community
enforce the rules which is where it
sounds like we're having all of our
problems or most of our problems so I
don't can you explain why you think they
might be of any help so a ruling of the
manufactured housing board can actually
be appealed and enforced
um I I'm not sure what the enforcement
mechanism is I've never lived through
that but SB 203 expanded the
jurisdiction of that board to make sure
that meetings were transparent and if a
member was expelled that they could go
come before this board to make sure that
was a fair process that they got due
process in that so I think with the
existing format of SB 203 there's the
thank you
Aaron did you have anything you wanted
thank you OfferUp
all right
um so as Tara mentioned I also work with
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund I
am one of those Tas who spends
hundreds of hours every year working
directly with a co-ops to help them
understand their bylaws to help them
untangle how to manage a confusing rule
um to make sure that they're doing their
handling their finances correctly
so
um so yeah and I on a personal note
that's really satisfying work and we get
to know people and they do deal with
very complex issues and I'm not
surprised that sometimes that becomes
difficult
but um most of them are doing an amazing
job
so I am here today to read a letter from
a woman named Mariana davio davio who's
a resident of a privately owned Park and
I'm just going to read her letter
because she asked us we do have the
letter so you don't have to you don't
have to read it yeah okay we do have the
letter thank you thank you right
okay
so I guess make sure everybody
understands the keywords here is invest
your own means it's owned by somebody
else
and communion these rocks are
of the resonance now own the park
and
from Moda we have I haven't heard from
Oda in a long time
good morning committee chair and
committee members
uh you haven't heard from motor in a
long time motor has sort of been defunct
for
several years prior to uh covid several
members uh left uh the organization and
the president of the organization passed
away and it sort of went defunct
uh
I and several of my colleagues along
with some support from the New Hampshire
communal land fund uh resurrected the uh
the organization
and so it's it's in its
uh uh infancy as a renewed organization
and I serve as its president's president
uh so I'm here to uh I'm sort of
representing them and I'm also a member
of medville Cooperative uh I've lived
there for 16 years I served on their
first elected board although I was
appointed because I came to the
community a few months after it was
purchased and uh
uh
people behave badly
that's no secret
and I think that a lot of what this is
about is is that we have three different
rsas that pretty much govern how we
operate as a Cooperative we have a the
consumer Cooperative rsas we have the uh
Corporation I mean the
uh yeah corporate cooperation uh rsas
and we have uh manufactured housing rsas
and a lot of the problems come when
those are not followed the way they
should be more so than even rules uh and
uh
and bylaws because those rules and
bylaws some what come from what is
dictated to how we should operate as a
consumer cooperative
uh
our mission is to uh my name is Kim
Capon I'm elected president of Moda
manufactured homeowners and Tennis
Association a mission is to support
manufactured homeowners who have
grievances with their owners rather
whether resident or investor owned I
spoke in favor of Senate Bill 203
as that is the board where we could
refer obvious violations of the rsas
that govern our owners and Leadership
as well as we could help with some
conflict resolution as it relates to
rules and bylaws of cooperatives
I am here to speak against Senate bill
Senate bills 203 would address the
interest of all manufactured homeowners
resident owned or investor owned roughly
two-thirds of all manufactured parks are
owned by investors and to suggest that
homeowners don't have issues of unfair
practices and investor products where
they have no recourse and even more
likely become subject to retaliation for
complaining make little sense
eliminating Senate Bill 203 to replace
it with possible solution arising from
study committee for Iraq oversight is to
leave the majority of homeowners
manufactured homeowners with no place to
go
for Relief they can bring their issues
to Moda but without a government
oversight board to review RSA violations
the most vulnerable homeowners are
forced to endure unfair and retaliatory
punishment from investor owners who
don't always have the best interest of
their tenants and homeowners now all
investor owners are equal in the fair
treatment of their tenants just as not
all rock leaders are looking out for the
best interests of their resident owners
many of these residents can't afford
attorneys to help them protect their
interest and have a conflict resolution
boot is having a conflict resolution
vote is important
affordable home ownership as well as
affordable rentals especially for lowest
income households is depleting rapidly
throughout our country something we have
all should be concerned about
manufactured homeowners struggle more
today than ever before is even their own
home as even they even as they own their
own home the lot fees are increasingly
becoming unaffordable as they struggle
to maintain their homes and keep up with
predatory investors knowing they have a
captive emphasis on captive homeowner
resident ownership of the communities
has proven to be a way of them to
maintain affordability and security but
that comes with the challenges as well
governance as rock owners sometimes go
awry depending on the resident's full
understanding of their rights as
resident owners manufactured homeowners
in investor-owned Parks also face
challenges of some owners neglecting
infrastructure needs as well as having
owner's rules and unreasonable lot fee
hikes that Force residents out
usually losing their biggest investment
and now facing homelessness or
subsidized housing both options everyone
would like to avoid
whatever this committee and eventually
the legislature decides the residents uh
the residents are the most aware of
their issues and many of them the most
capable of suggesting Solutions some of
us have lived in rock communities for
many years some have lived to invest
their own communities for many years as
well as many have been part of Both
Worlds the reason I support Senate Bill
203 is that the experience would be
valuable in understanding the issues in
law and the law and how best to craft
Solutions tailored to meet those
expectations of the law the manufactured
housing board being eliminated in
creating an oversight entity to review
rocks only is to leave thousands of
manufactured homeowners with no place to
turn when their rights are violated
please consider these issues carefully
as you deliberate on a solution thank
you very much for listening I'd be
delighted to answer any of your
questions
representative McLaren
oh thank you Mr chairman I I still don't
quite understand who you represent are
you a state run program or is it a
National Organization that you represent
that's a good question
Moda is is an organization that uh why
don't you explain what motor
what Boda stands for Moda stands for
manufactured homeowners and tenants
Association
it's basically an organization that uh
was pretty much sanctioned by the uh the
government of of New Hampshire
uh they they in the past have had a
representative
uh from their organization uh serving on
the manufactured housing board uh and
they generally are appointed by the by
the governor and their involvement was
investor owned Parks actually both but
mainly their the complaints they would
get would be from investor on Parks but
they also dealt with homeowner with
all set just a quick quote so you you
are against this bill and it's in its
present form
well there is no bill well in it the
study I should say the study itself
is uh to uh study oversight of rocks
if Senate Bill if this
replaces Senate Bill 203 it replaces the
manufactured housing board
then
investor owned
residents have no place to go
uh
this is no doubt that we believe I
believe that rocks and invests to own
residents need some sort of recourse
against uh Rogue boards on Resident
owned communities and uh uh investor uh
owned uh investors who are not taking
good care of of the infrastructure and
the things that are necessary for
someone to live in their home
for the record you did check that you
were in support of the bill
I
yeah well
for the record I messed up
okay because we just noticed you're on
the board of directors of
of the uh yes I am yeah I've served on
that board for coming up on I'm I'm
termed out at the end of this year yes
all right and I I spent a lot of time in
support of rock leaders across the
country I also have served in the past
on Rock USA which which serves to do the
same thing as a Community Loan Fund does
only does it nationally got it uh so I'm
I'm in support of of training and uh
supportive Rock leaders around the
country to uh make them better leaders
so that we don't face things like we're
facing today good representative Herbert
has a question if you're willing to take
it
um I'm curious if I understand correctly
the
the board the manufacturer housing board
is part of the office of licensure yes
it is and uh that's my understanding
what I don't understand is
uh 203 I'm getting mixed messages the
way I hear it sure Senate Bill 203
does Senate Bill 203
get rid of the manufacturer housing
board
Senate l203 does not it it actually
tries to revamp it so that it is so that
is uh
uh more more geared to to be fair to
resident owned communities as well as
investing on communities it's basically
needs better representation from
Resident owned communities just follow
one question for the question may
inquire if if uh if 203 were part of
uh the law
does that make the manufacturing board
manufactured housing board the place to
uh get a resolution
yes so it would
okay yeah yeah Senate
that's that's staying in place and if
Senate Bill 203 was was adopted
I don't believe this that this Senate
bill
okay representative spear just a quick
question you mentioned that the what
you're nervous about is that 64 could
possibly if we actually set up a
committee and all the rest of that that
it could actually get rid of uh 203. it
could do that but it also and and
getting rid of 203
uh doesn't uh leaves no place for
investor owned which I understand but
why do you think it will get
say it again why do
why do you that such a committee in
their work would get rid of SB 203 I I'm
it was it just a chance
203 is is facing some uh some
difficulties now uh if there's there's
movement afoot to to just to disband it
uh to eliminate it and uh
and so so you have two bills out there
that are sort of trying to address
uh the same issues uh one uh is is
facing issues of funding
uh and that's why there's there's a lot
of concern about it and then you have
this bill that's concerned about the
issues that resident owned communities
uh are face face from time to time in
terms of having some of their uh some of
their conflicts uh a place to go for
some of the issues that they have in
so so you so yeah
that there's two movements afoot and you
sort of have to get together and decide
how you best how to best to do this but
uh my understanding is that that 203 is
in danger of being uh the housing board
is in danger of being eliminated
because of funding uh for better and For
Worse that bill went to Edna
because it is regulated by the license
board and they're the regulator so
um
I'll leave it at that I understand
okay representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um
under Senate Bill 203 would it and
assuming it it goes through and uh the
manufacturer manufactured housing board
isn't otherwise eliminated
um
could the manufactured housing board uh
resolve the problems uh that Senate Bill
64 is apparently intended to address
that's that is that is what our hope is
yes
everybody else set
okay thank you very much
okay uh David Kirsch from
Brookside cooperative
good morning and thank you for your time
Mr chairman and members of this
committee my name is David Kirsch I
represent Brookside Cooperative we are a
small residential community in Hill New
Hampshire we were established as a
Cooperative roughly two years ago we
purchased our park in April of 2021.
we have had our issues
and
that's typical I guess of any new
business
that is going into a venture such as
owning a park and let me stress this
cooperatives are a business what we're
looking at here is a bill that is going
to step into the operation of a business
whether it is a resident owned business
or a
investor owned business we are a
business
people who are not members of that
business don't get a say in how it runs
it doesn't matter whether it's a
Cooperative or an investor-owned
business
we've heard testimony about one
particular park today
they got real mess and I agree the AG
should be involved
and I want to thank the member over here
who reminded us exactly why we're here
it's not here we're not here to trash
a specific Loan Fund or listen to the
complaints that people have about them I
have a feeling that that's other there
are other places for that we don't need
to be wasting your time
we also heard somebody say that nobody's
asking for any Financial or or anything
in this grant I am of the opinion that
your time is valuable
and this bill would be a waste of it
there's no need to
create a committee to look into just
rocks if you're going to do something
like that then as you've heard from
other people then we should be looking
at how investor owned communities have
um because just like a Cooperative
they're a business who own a park
now there's this manufactured housing
authority or Association or something
and you're going to hear from her soon
too
they represent investor own parks and
and then the manufacturers of of homes
there's a lot of profit to be made from
these Parks I mean if there wasn't
investment Equity firms would not be
buying up properties all over the
country from single-family homes to
buildings with you know residential
buildings to mobile parks or
manufactured home parks
um staying with the current vernacular
um but
what the difference is here between them
and and and co-ops is we're not looking
to make a profit out of here we're not
looking to squeeze every dime for the
minimum amount of expense we take care
of our Parks because there are homes we
live there my Park in the time that
we've been been a cooperative and own
the property we've taken care of
of infrastructure needs in water we're
currently working with an arbor Grant to
redo the entire Wastewater system we've
taken down trees that had posed a danger
to homes and people and and people that
our investor owners prior to purchasing
in this park had absolutely no intent of
dealing with
now do we have problems in our Park oh
yeah and we're small we're only 18 well
night currently 19 occupied residents is
out of 20 on site and um and in our time
we've had to
expel to members from our park for
violations and when we do that we give
them an opportunity to come before the
board and and and and give us their side
of the story one of them did
unfortunately he did so without a plan
for action so he ended up being expelled
the other one chose not to instead they
chose to continue to violate rules in
flagrant disregard of the authority of
the board and as a result we are in the
process of an eviction trial
now there's laws about all of this
there's all kinds of remedies that are
available when the people who are being
evicted called me personally I didn't
mention this I'm president by the way of
the Cooperative but when they called me
personally I said look I I can give you
some answers but really talk to your
lawyer you know and as far as
somebody mentioned I don't remember who
now
um about the um the the manufactured
housing board
um
the board of manufactured housing which
can handle resolution and can handle
disputes somebody mentioned that you
know people don't know it I think it was
that one woman from the other Park I
don't know it exists and yeah you're
right I didn't know it existed until
these bills came up
so somebody needs to get that word out
you know but um to be hitting on the on
one entity in this case the Community
Loan Fund which honestly what has that
got to do with this bill
absolutely nothing
we're not here to to talk about disputes
of one individual park or and and their
feelings about a Loan Fund we're here to
talk about whether or not you're going
to establish a committee that's going to
take up to two years
of your time
to determine whether or not
there needs to be legislation
that specifically targets resident owned
communities
when you go to the um
manufacture the board of manufactured
housing website and you look at all the
disputes that they handle and it's right
there for all to see
over 60 percent of them are from
investor owned communities
I think that if you're going to look for
a problem maybe that's where you should
be looking
not here well you can do it here too I
mean whatever but the thing I'm getting
at is
you know what's good for the goose is
good for the gander if you're going to
create this committee it needs to
include
investor owned communities as well but
honestly you have a board of met or
manual yeah Board of manufactured
housing already exists for dealing with
disputes
if the word needs to get out there that
it exists to more people let's do that
you know if we have an SB that's going
to expand the authority of that board
and give it more teeth let's do that
but I don't think we need to waste any
of your time
with a committee that's only going to
come back and ultimately say well we got
all right thank you very much for your
testimony any questions from committee
members representative billio yeah
uh are you did
10 the Senate hearing
or SP for SB 64. 54 64. this bill that
we're talking about I might have I've
been to so many of these things I can't
keep track anymore so
um there have been many senators and
representatives that you know are in
support of this bill and I think it came
out of committee
six to zero or I think was unanimous it
came out of committee unanimous to move
forward to the house just FYI would you
believe yeah would you believe what I
believe yeah I believe it and I and and
would you believe that we're going to be
hearing testimony from people who are
going to go back to the argument about
their personal and and experience on
their own Park and how they want to
blame a specific
company as you will for this I I you
know
tears are compelling
I almost feel like we need to box a
Kleenex here for some people
but let's not let's not insult our uh
I'm sorry
that's not what I meant any other
seeing none uh thank you very much for
so we're going to call
Deb Dube
from Allenstown Fairview Crossing
and Deb you asked for 10 minutes do you
think maybe we could do that in half
half that you asked for 10 minutes do
you think you could maybe do it in five
all right
we're about 40 minutes over time so
we want to we want to be considerate of
the bills that we have coming behind you
thank you yeah I understand
um
my name is Deb Dube and my husband
Richard and I have lived at Bear view
Crossing since 2001. we own our home
outright from using my law enforcement
retirement fund I am currently retired
from the Postal Service after completing
20 years of full-time
service
when we became a co-op in the year 2019
I had high expectations that we would be
able to care for the day-to-day business
of owning the mobile home park
manufactured home park would support
from Moroccan and clf this is what we
were told when we were when they were
campaigning for our future I certainly
felt comfortable with the assurance that
they would guide us through that and
meant in better Adventure the night we
voted to become a co-op I immediately
stood up and weighed 30 in cash for the
application fee required to start the
process
Amy and what NH employee wrote out the
receipt and told me that it was that
deducted from my membership fee we
quickly nominated five directors my
husband chose to become the vice
president
the board was later told that they had
interviewed several management companies
and chose the best suited before they
were done Michelle supery and Iraq NH
technical assistant told the board
members that they had to come up with a
management company that night
because they had one more to interview
where CFL would pull the loan she had
another woman with her that night and
told them that we had to use their her
company
her name was Joya Hughes from Compass
management and yes Joya was the young
lady I gave the thirty dollars in cash
the night we voted so she was
representing Rock
I was confused because
she's in rock one day and and now she's
running a management company that we're
told we have to have and my husband
stressed it was mandated
it turned out
The Joy was seriously unexperienced with
the job she double charged rent
charged me with a high bill of water
usage I told her that she made a mistake
I proved that she was supposed to build
a Jessica duby on 28th Turnpike in
Allenstown which is part of our property
um
her response was well I had to Bill it
somewhere
that was on the phone we had a resident
start a petition to remove her from rock
and rock did uh
Rock supported that Mr supery was also
removed and was replaced by Kelly
ciccarelli
flax fire management now replaced
Compass to be Keeper of the records
process eviction
Etc now I'm going to point out some of
the issues that we had to face over the
last couple of years
and we have nowhere to go and this is
why we need this bill we had a paid
maintenance maintenance employee that
also lived in the park he managed to be
nominated through the operations
director Rock NH and cflf knew this was
a conflict of interest it did nothing to
fix it several months later he moved
into the president's seat when the past
president moved out of the park he
requested a raise
requested to remove the rent bill
because of his employment he gave his
two crew members a Christmas bonus paid
vacation without
foreign approval still no help from work
or clf after we begged them to have him
removed from the board receipts were
missing written without documentation of
what which was charged and my husband
found one receipt with his initials
forged and when he questioned it it was
ignored two board members took my
husband out to the pits for a private
meeting he asked where the fourth member
was and they told him they didn't need
her Rick told them there was an
inappropriate and left
my husband was the chair of the bylaws
committee and he wanted to ensure the
paragraph that disallowed a paid
employee to serve on the board at any
capacity due to conflict the president
submitted the revised policy to
attorney Shepherd for approval and he
stated it was fine this was not
acceptable to him so he hired another
attorney
who we believe is still on our rolls
to try and put a stop to that closet
says that he can't work and get paid and
be on the board
and from what I understand that attorney
would not
okay that either
um he said that the rules that
by law
is
has never been voted on by the
membership
and it is still somewhere
um
and we don't have that paragraph put
into the one we have now
that says you cannot be a paid employee
uh
at this point the co-op is seriously
divided due to lack of agreements and
unstable treatment from some of the
board members Still Rock NH and clf
refused to step in to support us Kelly
and Chris glasby were at the membership
meetings board meetings and heard our
problems
in person and on Zoom we had two board
positions vacant since December and
January and rock NH CFL recommended we
wait until May for elections
this is not what we want we wanted to
have them filled in January when we
needed somebody
the
three p there's there's two people that
applied for those spots
or requested to join they were Prime uh
board members so they already have the
experience
of being on the board and they refuse to
put them on there
um
currently the management company runs
our meetings writes out our checks does
do not do Park inspections ignores our
file complaints three members
I'm on the finance committee as well as
two other members and we have been
selected and we signed paperwork to be
on the committee and have yet to be
called to a meeting we have a budget
that needed to be written for the two
the 20 uh 23 24 term we don't know who
wrote it up but I hear it has been at
the assistance of Foxfire management
last Friday I was shown a YouTube
hearing of bits uh State uh Senate Bill
203 with testimonies given by Louise
right out and Bonnie Garris that
afternoon
uh there was a gene Wright who wrote a
nasty post on the Rock NH Facebook group
about a small handful of angry residents
from one commun Community lashed out
to
Community Home Loan
would you like to hear what she wrote
okay we're we're really tight on time is
it is that written Titan's testimony
that we can have in sort of the
permitted file that would that would be
great we will make sure that all the
[Music]
and was always
but mine was also because I wanted my
husband to hear
she wanted she called but gave leading
questions of getting information
that I supposedly needed she wanted to
make sure I got it the only in info I
was looking for was getting the
management company's contract to read
what they're supposed to be doing she
said the post had been deleted and
she's referring to the the nasty one
um okay she wanted to know if if I was
coming here today
and
we very much appreciate your testimony
then yes we very much want your your
notes so we can get them in the
permanent record well great thank you
um okay we had two more cards left and
we're running tight on time here so uh I
will ask them to uh please stick to the
two minutes that you wrote on your card
hi um my name is Chris Nyland I live at
um roc's 100th Park in Derry New
Hampshire for the past nine years
what you're getting right now is um not
my word but the actual words from
pretend board members and what that
document the first document shows is
we've had no meetings monthly or
annually for four years
we've had no elections for four years
we're missing four hundred thousand
dollars we haven't been given fiduciary
reports in four years we have no rules
committee
we haven't been told about the
eight-year lawsuit that cost us 160
thousand dollars
we pretend board members filling in the
wetlands
we have pifas in our water chlorine
septic
when I brought it to the attention of
the Community Loan Fund year after year
that we're not having meetings and we're
not having annual meetings and when they
tried to get out of having another
meeting this year they had me beat up
got all my teeth knocked out
then they prepared an attorney letter to
me and violated me on three violations
and then they've been taking my rent
money thousands to pay for the attorney
Bill
and now every couple days I get a new
we need an oversight committee something
really powerful because we have in our
park we have
there's no meeting so how can you make
yourself a board of directors
how we need a powerful committee to to
to to enforce I mean how do you how do
you get those Crux out of the top
positions we can't do it from within
because they have the power of the
attorney they have Community Loan Fund
they have our Park management company
they have all the rules in the court
system under landlords and the only the
only thing that we can sue them on is if
somehow the board of directors has
ruined your peace and Tranquility of
your lot other than that we have no
legal remedy to us at all and if you
enter into that
realm of uh right to quiet enjoyment of
the park you're into uh three lawsuits
which includes six appeals up to the
Supreme Court where they only had the
two justices for the couple years which
slowed the case down another three years
so uh but the case you know this book is
a guideline for management but Community
Home Loans they don't actually know how
to run a mobile home park they're just
giving you information of how to run a
meeting but they don't know about
property deeds and setting up lots and
water systems and sewer systems and and
you know what I mean they just don't
thank you for your time today
uh do you have any questions does
anybody have uh we do have a question
I'm quick do you think we need a
committee that has no teeth or do you
think we need legislation with teeth we
need legislation with teeth these are
these are criminal offenses I mean you
you're you're you're silencing the vote
of 58 members in the in the community we
we're entitled to a monthly vote in the
year we vote the secretary's minutes
have to be presented at the annual
meetings and and so when you silence us
like that for four years and then and
then on the fourth year when they
finally ordered to have a meeting then
all of a sudden four names appear on the
sheet because other than that we didn't
representative Gibbs thank you
uh is your Park investor owned or
resident owned residue you and do you
own your unit or lease it
resident owned Community turns out is a
slogan like Live Free or Die in New
Hampshire it has no real meaning it it's
it we don't really own anything we're
not stakeholders the park isn't worth
any money if it was sold we couldn't get
any money I own my own home
in the park the way community won't find
uh tells it is we or only have a per uh
forever lease on the actual Foundation
under our mobile homes and everything
else is Co-op property but the lawsuit
says if you're going to make us take
care of our Lots by mowing it in the
branches and the insurance then
this program doesn't work because you
can't make us take care of our lots and
buy lawn mowers and all that stuff and
then not allow us to have full use of
the lot
if you know what I'm saying
representative there was who is a
co-sponsor of this bill is that correct
okay thank you Mr chairman have you
considered going to the attorney general
I have absolutely called the attorney
general they have no jurisdiction over
it although um although it falls under
the guidelines of RSA 301 and 301 has
like 10 sections where it goes to proxy
voting and voting and monthly meetings
and annual meetings and that's part of
the bill that Senator avard put in on
the SB 203 the original one had but is
the the testimony of the manager hack
should housing board they haven't
gaveled in since 2019.
there's only one member they have
handled no complaints and if you go
through manufactured housing because I
own a house in a private park too
because it's such a dangerous situation
to own in this in this I have to have a
second backup so I have a second back up
the exact same home in a private park
and over the six years that I've owned
that the rent's only gone up twenty
dollars and every time I show up to that
home it's better than the last time I
left it because they do all the odd work
if that makes any sense so I have both
because it's such a hostile and because
I'm always having eviction notices you
have to have a backup so I pay for two
mobile homes I own two mobile homes
outright one in Roc Park which I live
full time but I also have the backup
thank you very much for your time
and you will I'm asking to do the two
minutes for me please
I'll give that after
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee
my name is Bonnie garies and I'm from
Bayview Crossing Cooperative in
Allenstown I hope that some of you may
remember me when I was here on a similar
issue last year
I am here today along with others to ask
you to please support SB 61 that will
establish a study committee to develop a
dispute resolution program for Resident
owned manufactured housing parks and
oversight of Resident owned
housing Parks this bill is absolutely
needed and it is a must
bear view as well as many other co-ops
and I do have to add I have about 80
co-ops now that have been reaching out
to me with the similar problems that
we've been working for years to have our
board comply with our rules and bylaws
and not just with our rules on bylaws
but also trying to get them to comply
with our lender requirements
because of the board and the New
Hampshire Community Loan funds lack of
fiduciary responsibility we have been in
default with a Community Home Loan Fund
and Providence Banks since September
2021 with no end in sight
and our community and many other and
many others complaints are not addressed
by the boards leaving us without a voice
for example the boards have had private
meetings in which the public was unable
to attend they spend money on behalf of
the park without the required
authorization of Park members and not
provided financial information to the
park members when asked
this is a really important issue
we asked for financial information from
the board for over two years ago
and recently received information now we
have discovered that we have a
significant amount of
unreconciled funds misappropriated funds
and more
without the development of a dispute
resolution program for a resident owned
communities are packable and others will
resident owned communities are
multi-malooned all the companies and due
to our financial mess we really need to
determine if there was an oversight of
Resident owned communities and it's not
just the communities that have to have
oversight it's the Community Home Loan
Fund
this bill is a step in the right
direction in protecting the rights and
interests of all the residents in all
Resident owned communities
I respectfully ask the committee to pass
this bill
to give all of our members of co-ops an
opportunity to seek some sort of relief
I hope my testimony will not put a
larger Target on my back by the New
Hampshire Community Loan Fund as they
have done enough damage to my character
because I've been vocal and I just want
to let you know that I am looking into
legal counsel for this
I will be happy to answer any questions
that you have and thank you for your
time
thank you very much
okay
do you know questions
um having no more cards we'll close the
public hearing
and yes this will go to subcommittee
okay
um I need to say we run very late here
today so
um we're going to do uh weights and
measures and then the business entities
so if anybody's here for the wage of her
uh Senate Bill 197 we will be taking it
seeing none okay we'll do this quickly
hopefully
Senate Bill 67 and
um oh shoot I just said I sent Grant
home
uh so um Cheryl air from the Department
yes Cheryl you're here so
[Music]
hello Mr chairman and members of the
committee
for the record my name is Cheryl air I
am the director of weights and measures
which is under the Department of
Agriculture markets and food I am to I
am here to speak in support of Senate
Bill 67. the first proposed change
provides clarification of Authority for
us to charge for services provided by
the state's Metrology lab that are
already in rural
the second proposed change refers to RSA
43811 and offers housekeeping changes to
provide Clarity to the statute
the last change is relative to RSA 438.5
field standards and Equipment under the
current law all field standards used to
carry out the provisions of the weights
and measures Act
as stated shall be verified at least
once a year thereafter by comparison
with this state standards this is
challenging in several ways
the state Metrology lab is not equipped
to calibrate certain field standards
this includes the 100 gallon gallon
volumetric prover used to test fuel and
to test fuel and bulk oil meters the 100
and 220 gallon volumetric provers used
to test liquid petroleum gas meters and
linear measures used to inspect firewood
these have been sent out to other state
accredited or nist recognized
Laboratories which is a technical
violation of the current law
with the development of new technology
such as electric vehicle charging
stations or meters dispensing hydrogen
fuel
the practice of sending out our testing
equipment would need to continue since
we do not have the space or equipment
available to test these field standards
in our own Metrology lab
when the original language was written
we were using brass standards in the
field that were not as stable as the
stainless steel standards used today
which have been documented through
history of stability
the stainless steel weights used by your
investigators in the field have never
been adjusted after calibration since we
are also very diligent diligent about
they have always maintained stability
within the tolerance parameters
calibration on a yearly basis has been
shown to be unnecessary unless a field
standard has been damaged linear
measures such as tape measures could go
10 years between calibrations
the proposed language allows us to
require that all newly purchased State
field test equipment be verified upon
initial receipt then those field
standards would be verified at intervals
as recommended by the National
Conference on weights and measures
handbook 105 series by our own Metrology
lab
or a National Institute of Standards and
Technology nist recognized lab as well
as an international laboratory
accreditation cooperation signatory
accredited lab
that is all I have for you thank you so
much for your time and your
consideration
great any questions from the committee
members
Cena thank you very much for your
testimony and I do have a copy of my
comment clerk very much appreciates that
and I might want to reread it myself to
think I can understand all of this
all right thank you
okay we will now close the public
hearing uh excuse me recess the public
Hearing in 67 so that uh
Senate Senator Gannon can have Grant
Bussey actually introduce it which
unfortunately sent him away thinking
that we were running too late but
um that we're going to break recess for
lunch and be back here at 1 15.
foreign
so uh
Grant come on up
we're gonna do a quickie here because we
already
opened 67 so we want to uh we recessed
it and so
um
yeah weights and measures so we already
got from the Department to testimony so
okay I I realized
you have what you need to know Senator
Gannon is satisfied yeah well we'd like
you to read his absolutely good
afternoon Mr chairman member of the
Commerce Committee I am still Grant
bossy here to uh introduce Senate Bill
67 on behalf of Senator again in the
prime sponsor uh as you know from the
Department the Department of Agriculture
asked Senator Gannon to introduce the
bill making some changes to the state's
wages and measures statutes most of
these included in the National weights
and measures handbook the Senate Edna
committee adopted an amendment suggested
by commissioner Jasper and the full
Senate approved Senate Bill 67 on the
consent calendar uh thankfully the
department has already asked the
questions which I would defer anyway uh
Senator again and thanks you for your
support and consideration of Senate Bill
67. thank you okay great
any questions see you then thank you
very much
okay all right now we can officially
close the hearing on 67.
so
all right
okay well actually yeah so
what I want to do uh where's my oh I
um
all right okay yeah let's go ahead and
we don't have much of 21 right okay
let's open up 21.
yep go ahead
thank you Mr chairman uh good afternoon
I remain Grant bossy here to introduce
Senate Bill 21 on behalf of Senator
Gannon the bell's Prime sponsor he does
appreciate you uh putting all his bills
together so we could pinch it in one go
Senator Gannon filed this bill at the
request of the Liquor Commission uh this
bill would give Brewers and microbrewers
additional time to complete their
paperwork and it would alleviate
concerns they had about the existing
deadline which is on the 10th of each
month other deadlines such as the rooms
and meals tax are on the 15th of each
month this bill would permit electronic
filing which is not currently allowed
the Senate passed Senate Bill 21 on the
consent calendar Senator Gannon thanks
you for your consideration of support of
Senate Bill 21. I'm happy to get any
okay anybody have any questions about
going from the 10th to the 15th
well good thank you
and
the department will speak if anybody
cares
right
anybody anybody wants to ask a question
commission see none all right we'll
close the public hearing
21 excuse me
and we'll wait four minutes so that I
can be
now yeah we're gonna be doing 197
momentarily here
all right so for the committee
um
it's scheduled again for next Wednesday
uh uh and then the following Wednesday
because I think it's the 26th vacation
week
school vacation week you know there's no
school vacation
okay so uh
then I have the the two business bills
uh that we have left and then I was
gonna do the liquor subcommittee in the
afternoon
of the 26th 26th okay and
um
but in the morning we'll do
[Music]
Uh Kevin avard's Bill related to
products labeling information guide for
requirements for cannabis products and
the prohibition sale of hemp products
and
the only other and then the other one
was the relative to resale of event
tickets
is that ticket scalping
so yeah so we have had tickets calping
in the past in this committee
and it was
valencourt
Steve Allen court and he he would start
off with well I guess I should be
those three yeah I know which which some
committee do you want them under oh I
uh Mr chairman what are we doing with
the rest of today's uh agenda we're
right now I'm just waiting to 1 30
I recessed the hearing on
um
the 197. so
and they're the sponsors here the
Department's here and the Secretary of
State's office is here and we're just
waiting so that I can do it uh on time
and not be accused of starting a hearing
prematurely thank you
so um
you know in the old days
the old days when we didn't have to
schedule exec sessions
the chair could just look around the
room says okay we have a quorum so you
know chair rules we go to exact session
and we could actually vote on bills and
some people didn't really like that
because sometimes they've got pills got
killed when nobody was in the room to
know to watch it so we can't do that
anymore so now I just have to kind of
and and I don't know jokes
so we will do next Wednesday the 19th
and the 26th
um we don't have to have anything out of
committee until it's like June first of
June so uh the month of uh
May will will be doing again we'll do
Wednesdays and we'll be doing
subcommittees and then and then
obviously the exact session
in there
where are you going
of May the sixth of May yeah okay for
how long are you gonna be gone oh
okay well it's a nice time that's right
it's a nice time to go to Paris
Springtime in Paris
it must be a song
I'm moving right Springtime in Paris
that's right
okay we're close enough all right so
we'll open up the public hearing on
Senate bill 197.
thank you Mr chairman uh this will be my
final at bat with you unless a senator
of course asked me to pinch head on
short notice uh I remain Grant bossy
from the New Hampshire Senate here to
introduce Senate Bill 197 on behalf of
Senator Gannon the prime sponsor Senator
Gannon introduced this bill at the
request of the Department of State it
includes five changes one New Hampshire
organizations would be allowed to
appoint an agent for service of process
in the state two foreign business
entities would be required to affirm in
their application to transact that they
are in good standing in the state of
incorporation or formation three
domestic and foreign benefit
corporations would be allowed to use the
ending PBC public benefit Corporation in
their name when qualifying to do
business in the state for the process of
limited Partnerships to change their
registered agent and office address
would be simplified and finally five
fees for certified copies would be
changed to one dollar per document and
the department would be allowed to
establish fees for bulk address changes
that are filed electronically the Senate
passed Senate Bill 197 on the consent
calendar the deputy secretary is here to
answer all of your questions and Senator
again and thanks you for your
consideration and support of Senate Bill
197. thank you
great thank you very much
and
good afternoon
good afternoon Mr chair committee
members I am Aaron Hennessey deputy
secretary of state and with me is Tom
Connolly he is the director of the
corporate division
um is that your correct title yes yes
thank you
um we had asked Senator Gannon to file
this bill for us in the Senate Tom had
brought to our attention some what we
consider minor changes that make a big
difference in a lot of companies lives
ultimately there's not a huge fiscal
note to this but it does a lot of
cleanup on the books for us and kind of
gets things
um in order and treats different types
of organizations more fairly compared to
each other
Grant went through and did a good
summary I think of the details of it but
I'm happy to have Tom go through and
give you more details if you have any
uh yeah why did you do telemetism
indicated here the uh my name is Tom
Connolly I'm the director of
Corporations for the Secretary of State
um the bill is was introduced on our
behalf um the let's say I think the
analysis is a pretty clean
straightforward indication of what each
of the sections of the bill do
um specifically we're trying to do here
is accommodate
um increase of uniformity for for the
various entity types
um the first need to indicated in
section one of the bill has to do with
registered agents that most entities in
the state are required by a lot of have
a registered agent in New Hampshire with
a physical address as it turns out
domestic non-profits are one entity type
that don't have them but actually we
have non-profits who come to us that
have asked you for the ability to build
a appointed agent primarily because they
want to make it easy for people to find
them and secondly if they're small
non-profit and they don't have their own
offensive physical address that they can
provide an address it's not an address
of one of their members here right now
with the domestic nonprofit they have to
have a physical New Hampshire address so
someone sets up a non-profit in your
town and they're just getting started so
somebody in that was on that board
remember that's going to have to give
their street address their personal
address as an address for for for a
principal office this will allow them to
to use a third party to do that um it
would be entirely voluntary
um as I said they're about now they're
about 11 000 non-profits registered in
New Hampshire and we think that on the
first year that there would be several
hundred that would probably take
advantage of this this provision it also
allows for example um foreign Banks
Banks don't register with the secretary
of state but save someone like Wells
Fargo who's a National Bank wants to
have an address in New Hampshire they
don't have a branch they can use this
filing type to be able to register and
file and have an agent in the state
um
the uh second item in the bill relates
to foreign corporations right uh several
years ago we removed a requirement that
foreign companies have to provide us a
proof of that they're in good standing
in their home state that made the
process a little faster we rely on the
information they provide them and then
Most states have this information
available online so we're able to look
and verify it ourselves
um however but we've asked and do in
here is to provide a provision here with
the entity has to to tell us that they
have actually checked and that they are
a good standing before they apply to do
business in New Hampshire
yeah so the key word that the foreign
doesn't necessarily mean International
that's correct anybody who's not a New
Hampshire Corporation will be considered
a called a foreign corporation so for
example each of the Delaware
Corporations if you go to the Delaware
website you can't tell if a company is
in good standing or not unless you pay a
30 fee but the company would have to
attest to us when they're registering
with us that they have checked and
verified that they're in good standing
in their home state before they register
um I the section three of the bill
relates to benefit corporations New
Hampshire's had benefit corporations
um since 2016 I believe it was first
authorized however New Hampshire law is
a bit unique from other states as it
doesn't provide them an opportunity to
indicate that they are a public benefit
Corporation in their name using that
ending PBC which is rather common in
other states and if a benefit
Corporation from another state comes to
New Hampshire we require them to add an
anchor corporate limited to their name
because it doesn't meet our requirements
so this would simply allow benefit
corporations both foreign or domestic to
use ending PVC if the as part of their
um section 4S do with limited
Partnerships they're the one type of
business that doesn't have the same sort
of process in place where if they want
to change their registered agent rather
than filing a statement of change
they're required to actually file an
amendment to their certificate of a
certificate limited partnership and that
tends to be a burden that tends to be a
an item because it costs more it's a
little more complicated folks don't do
it we want to make sure that they're
keeping their registered agent
information up to date so this would
allow them to file those statements the
same way that other businesses do by
simply filing a change of agent rather
than having to actually amend their
certificate a limited partnership and a
registered agent could also going back
to that section one could be that their
residency would be with a registered
agent's residence or local that's
correct yeah they could use a resident
agent's address for for all of their
contact information yes
and then those section five the last
section analysis relates to fees charged
with the Secretary of State
um one thing we've not yet automated the
Secretary of State's office is the
ordering of certified copies if you want
it for a closing you need to get a
certified copy of the Articles
incorporation all your amendments that
request is still required to go to our
office we go through and determine
whether we have all the documents
um available in our online in our system
and then go ahead and generate a
certificate a um a set of documents for
for a uh for a certified copy
um by changing what we're going to do is
rather than charging a dollar per page
as now most State most of the requests
people don't actually want the paper
they just want us to email them a PDF
that provides the certificate and all
the all the documents are listed there
but the cost is based on actually a
dollar per Pages based on the process of
thinking you had to get up and
physically copy these these documents so
to make that process simpler we'd like
to Simply charge a fee of a dollar per
document instead of one dollar per page
and that way people can see a list of
documents select those documents know
exactly what it's going to cost and be
able to pay for it right up front so
that will simplify the process it lowers
the fee it actually does lower the bit
for entities that have a big long list
of members yeah they'll have more well
folks have a lot of documents on file or
a lot of pages especially older
businesses uh that will definitely save
them a few dollars when they when they
do that
and the other item that relates to these
here it relates to registered agents um
or law firms that change their address
um we had a recent example we had a law
firm up north that changed their office
and they act as the agent for many of
the companies that their clients have
right so they had seven they took their
physical address and then they had to
file 70 agent changes or address agent
address changes Each of which it cost of
fifteen dollars so by moving their
office they occurred a thief about a
thousand dollars just to Simply file an
address change with us and we think that
for for those sorts of situations that
with automation now we don't need to
assess that sort of fee it's not the
kind of transaction where we have to
physically process a single document for
each item we now have a process on our
website where
um Law Firm can go when they can find
all the companies that they it's aged
for can simply select them and file a
single filing with us so we still charge
them the same fifteen dollars per entity
so this would give us some ability to be
able to set fees for those transactions
that would be a little more uh again
more friendly to the business
environment into the people who are
acting the lawyers because mostly law
offices are the ones are registered
agents in many cases Law Offices or um
private service companies that also
offer that service and accountants yes
that's so nice of you guys to lower
their costs Law Offices when they move
their own
less expense for moving the office okay
okay any questions from the committee
foreign
um actually that's the same category
again anybody outside of New Hampshire
would be considered to be a foreign
corporation even if it's International
there was something that we need to look
at as far as the fiscal note or is it a
wash because of the fee structure change
and if you want to speak to that
sure I'm not sure what version of the
bill that you have but um our analysis
was approximately
um thirty thousand dollars in Lost
Revenue per year for the corporate
division but the corporate division does
bring in a lot of Revenue and Tom can
tell you about what just happened that
um for annual business filings and the
good news on that
um the uh yes indicated that the cost
potentially we know most registered
agents these these large address changes
don't happen that frequently
um in this past year we had two of those
two two
move address changes one that one law
firm and one a Service Company Each of
which uh that resulted in filing fees of
about thirty thousand dollars but the
previous fiscal year we had none we had
no no businesses that moved at the time
so the the amount of money we would lose
would would be it's hard to gauge
because it's not a frequent occurrence
as far as the cost of doing the making
changes on our systems will accommodate
this
um we can do that within the provisions
of our current software vendor contract
so we don't have to ask for any
additional funds
about business filing since I know
there's there's much concern in talking
the media right now about the
possibility of an economic downturn
um usually do business filings is a good
indicator of what the business Community
is thinking and how it's going to happen
if
um this past month in March we had a um
there was not a record but it was close
to one of our highest months we had uh
1675 new LLC formations in New Hampshire
typically 1100 1200 a month it's been
more or less our constant in the last
two years here so we haven't seen any
drop in business filing business
activity right now
um last year we brought in and revenue
were told please it was um 4.5 million
and unrestricted revenue for
um business filings and we certainly
great
anyone else would like to speak on
Senate Bill 197
see none
we will close the public hearing
so now we're ready for
okay
jeez
John how are you I'm doing well how are
you I'm doing great I have to say when I
was a member of the committee it wasn't
so um so expansive it's well it's this
new configuration I still haven't gotten
used to it yeah it's not as intimate and
cozy it's well I always kind of like
being back there you know having the
you're glowing plenty
said but the best part was during coven
I had
and Fitzgerald come take a picture of me
sitting in it and I was sitting here but
in the chair
and then
when I had the zoom I had my that my is
my zoom background and you wouldn't be
amazed at how many people even Aiden
said geez are you are you really there
yeah then some people had cats walking
down I didn't even know you were really
at home in your pajamas well we won't
talk about it
sir and chairman we're wearing on a
given day but uh no I would have to say
that I would I always because I never
know when you might I might have to get
up and and who doesn't I don't I don't
wanna I don't have that happen
well it's just it's I'm very conscious
now because we're all this is all
YouTube so good
and we'll be there forever
that's very reassuring
okay we're close enough uh we'll open up
the public hearing and hear from our
former member of the committee
Senator Murphy good afternoon good
afternoon Mr chairman it's a pleasure to
be back with Commerce see a lot of
familiar faces this is a very simple
bill it's really a housekeeping measure
the beer distributors in New Hampshire
benefit from a little quirk in the law
that requires all bills to be paid
within 10 business days
if that doesn't happen they report the
licensee to The Liquor Commission which
maintains a list and then
businesses on the list can't be sold
alcohol
um
the number hasn't been changed in about
30 years and at the low current uh
number of 100 that's actually kind of a
detriment to the Distributors because
they get fined if they fail to report
those businesses to the list
um and if you read the minutes Liquor
Commission it actually happens fairly
often so all this bill does is update
that number to 250. so it's a little bit
higher so they won't get fined as much
and Distributors aren't running around
chasing checks for 101 dollars
so it's a very simple bill but I'm happy
to take questions
where's Scott
he told me he supported the bill but
it'd be nice if he was here to say that
okay
it is it is a very unusual circumstance
that the state
has this in its statute yes it is very
unique
any questions from committee members yes
I guess I don't know
what would be an example of when we
would need to do that can you kind of
paint that picture because this is all
new to me I see so if you have a
restaurant say that
buys a keg of any beer and it costs 150
dollars
the beer distributor will show up on the
10th day and say you need to give me a
check for 150 and I mean they'll drive
to the restaurant and ask for the check
and if they fail to do that or maybe the
business owner isn't in maybe they're
saying Concord or somewhere they could
be reported they would have to be
recorded to the list and they could not
order any additional alcohol until they
had paid that check for 150 dollars so
all this does is change the number from
100 to 250.
for the question we inquire
and how often does that happen
thank you chairman it's honestly I am a
liquor license C it's never happened to
me and I've been doing it for 17 years
but I read the minutes of the commission
regularly and it does happen enough
um
I have probably seen two to three dozen
times in the last few years where
various Distributors have been charged a
and part of the the rationale behind it
is because the beer distributors are
collecting the 30 cents a gallon tax
so the state Nature has an interest to
make sure the tax got paid in a timely
fashion so in this case the we're
holding the distributor responsible
and uh rather than
somewhere down the line but sure
yes representative just a quick question
10 days just it just kind of surprises
me that that's the time period because
most standard businesses you know even
from a dentist or something give you 30
days so just out of curiosity why 10
days I think we'd have to go back in
time to the legislature that was in
place in the 1970s or 80s when this bill
was law was originally passed but it has
always been 10 days
all we're seeking to do here is change
the number from 100 to 250 to updated
the commission wants its money
paid in a timely fashion
representative Gibbs
thank you
um
I'm curious why not
um uh take the specifics of the
reportable amount and the time limit out
of the statute and instead say that the
reportable amount and the time limit
shall be established by regulation by
The Liquor Commission and in that way if
it were necessary to change it again in
the future it could be changed without
having to change the statute
the question I tend to myself I tend to
favor things being done through
legislature I think that's why we're
here I'm not a big fan of rulemaking as
a way to set policy having said that I
think also the Distributors they like
the current law because they benefit
because the law forces licensees to pay
the bill and
I think they would be resistant to
granting that sort of latitude to the
commission
thank you
good answer
okay
oh yes representative
in real world terms what does the 250
dollars represent to a business in terms
I guess in purchasing power that is
approximately the cost of one keg of
Guinness
um it's the cost of less than two kegs
of Bud Light
um it's probably in the neighborhood of
six cases eight cases of beer most beers
it's not a whole lot of product in other
words
very housekeeping it's pretty minimal
yes
thank you
look great thank you thanks chairman
see anybody else would like to testify
on Senate Bill 98
.
[Music]
okay
did I take him I don't know I go well
yeah take everything take it all
good afternoon Senator Murphy what a
pleasure to see you again thank you Mr
chairman it's great to be in front of
you again whereas the last bill was
extremely simple and straightforward
this bill is much more complicated
um and I'm sorry for that I can
say that was a good time to drink some
coffee if you have any uh I've got to
explain something called The Jones Act
of 1920.
the Jones Act was passed in the
aftermath of World War One
The Merchant Marine fleet was used to
transport goods and soldiers
to Europe
for use in fighting and
as a result of that
um
to his actress passed the Jones act
basically says in a nutshell that any
ship that is engaging in Commerce from
one U.S port to another U.S port
must be built in American shipyards must
be crewed by American sailors
and must be owned by American ship uh
shipping interest
so
that might have made some sense in 1920
at the time we had thousands and
thousands and thousands of ships
we had hundreds and hundreds of
shipyards across the country
today while Japan has over a thousand
shipyards and China has over 2 000
shipyards
we have only seven major shipyards in
the United States only one of which
builds commercial cargo ships
it cost three times more to build a ship
here than it does overseas it costs 2.7
more times more to operate a U.S flag
vessel
there are as of now
less than 200 qualified ships to engage
in port to port Commerce the United
States the average age is over 30 years
old
which is basically at their life
expectancy
so when you have
a high demand for a service and you have
a limited Supply what happens to price
it goes up
those goods that would be transferred
from point to point using water which is
actually fairly environmentally friendly
has to get pushed onto
trains and trucks which are not as
environmentally friendly so there's two
costs to look at here there's the
financial cost which we all pay there's
so the bill is very simple we're not in
a position to
Grant waivers as a legislature to the
Jones act but we are in a position to
come up with a number
and I filed this bill last November
December because at the time we were
facing extremely high heating oil cost
now since then we've had a fairly mild
winter and that was lucky it worked out
for us
but uh
the bill seeks to come to a
a number for what it costs
our citizens
for heating oil and energy prices I'd
ask the department of energy to
calculate that number given existing
information
um for the record the president can
grant waivers and has granted waivers to
certain States and certain Pro in
certain situations Alaska had a waiver
at one point when they had difficulty
getting gasoline for example in the wake
of a hurricane Puerto Rico had a waiver
granted so there was there is a
possibility to have waivers the idea is
that we get this number that gives us
additional
information to push for a waiver for
ourselves if that were to happen again
so
if I explain the Jones act in enough
detail I can certainly I handed out some
additional information but I'm happy to
s
foreign
state
for the rest of this thing
in November the heating oil prices the
heating oil difference in price between
Minnesota and non-vote
state
and New Hampshire was 30 seconds the
difference New Hampshire was five
dollars and eighty cents a gallon
Minnesota was 30 cents less according to
the Department of origin
a month later they realized that the
winter wasn't going to be that bad
and the price brought a dollar a gallon
all across everybody and that includes
every state in New England
Indiana Virginia Delaware Oakland States
they're all about a Dollar by December
22nd
as of today who gives you phase blessed
than Minnesota pays for heating one
that's according to the Department of
energy that's a non-vote state versus a
so in your in the bill it talks about
our high energy prices for heating oil
when in fact it is any higher than a
state that has no vote
and right now it's actually a little bit
less
I just want to understand what it is
we're looking for here and what the
point of all this is when some of the
numbers aren't backing up what you're
saying
well I want to congratulate your
representative for uh asking me the
longest question I've ever heard in my
nine years as a member of this
legislature
hahaha
so
would you believe I understand the gist
of your question my hypothesis without
pulling out a map is that Minnesota
probably has dramatically closer access
to oil fields in Canada North Dakota Etc
and probably has better pipeline access
than we do here in New Hampshire
um
oil flows across the country in a number
of ways train pipeline shipping Etc and
while they may not have boats uh
directly in Minnesota they certainly
have closer access to the pipe to the
oil fields and to Pipelines
follow on to that please if you don't
mind
I do understand that absolutely
what I'm trying to get at is the
difference and I do understand our
pipeline problems what I'm trying to
understand is the difference with
what the impact is
of the Jones act specifically in this
one area which you call out in the bill
when in fact it doesn't seem to be
the difference that you're calling out
the point of the bill is to arrive at
the number
how can we say there is no impact to the
Jones Act without asking the question
okay
yes representative
as I understand that the Jones Act is a
federal act given that how does this
study accomplish anything aside from
more paper since no matter what the
findings would be this legislature would
have no authority over the Jones Act
thank you that's certainly a very valid
question I am not one for make work
especially in our busy
state agencies
however
it must drive up the cost of of heating
oil and energy prices in some way
it's simply seeking to quantify the cost
it may be
20 cents a kilowatt hour
or five cents a kilowatt hour one cent a
kilowatt hour it simply seeks to
quantify the number
there may not be an I mean it's going to
the idea is that if we have that number
and then we're in a position to uh Lobby
Washington for our Jones act waiver if
we were to have a difficult winter which
we luckily managed to avoid but just
like you I saw my heating oil prices
Spike and my my electric prices
Spike that man happened across the state
I'm still paying what 22 cents a
kilowatt hour from eversource right now
I believe
so
anyway
I have net metering so you know just
just been bigger checks
representative Hammond thank you Mr
chair thank you Senator first testifying
and taking our questions
um
understanding that the global oil Market
is a large fungible market so that
prices uh here impact prices everywhere
and vice versa could you explain how the
Jones act affects how fuel oil arrives
on our Shores
it comes from
do you understand can you explain to us
the uh the route that it takes that it
otherwise might not if the Jones act
wasn't in effect thank you for the
question so
let's say oil is produced in Saudi
Arabia and then it is transported here
to New Jersey where the uh there's many
many refineries and it's produced and
it's refined in the heating oil at that
location
it can then not be shipped directly from
New Jersey
to uh to Boston for uploading and
transportation here it's got to go to a
and that extra time
adds cost and that cost is as always
passed on to the end consumer American
Oil can't be shipped out of uh let's say
Louisiana
and transported to New Jersey for for uh
Refinery it must go somewhere else
can I answer your question sufficiently
thank you
yeah other people have to
so represent Burroughs
yes Senator thanks for taking my
question
um my question is that you know it's a
federal Jones Act is a federal
um law
and would it be more effective to have a
study that combines the New England
states rather than having each state do
it individually wouldn't it perhaps have
more impact on the federal government
and looking at this issue
thank you for the question and that may
well be the case
the law is targeted towards New
Hampshire because that's where we live
this is the legislature for New
Hampshire so that's why the the
um the bill is written as it is
also I think that the department of
energy is going to be
um it's going to have at its fingertips
information specific to New Hampshire
and in a way that's easier than say
information
for the region
that's why
representative Gibbs
thank you uh you mentioned that
um oil that is shipped from foreign that
is
um
uh comes from oil wells in foreign
countries
um and then a ship for instance to New
Jersey and and refined in the oil
refineries there
um would then have to go to a foreign
country before being shipped uh to New
Hampshire
[Music]
um but my question is is that in fact
true and I ask it because I heard
um
a speaker
um from
um a company
that does shipping
um in and out of uh Portsmouth
who uh said that while uh large there
are a few to know large tanker vessels
uh that are Jones act qualified that
there are in fact many uh barges uh that
ship oil from one U.S port to another
that our Jones act qualified and then in
fact a great deal of oil does come into
New England ports in that way via U.S
there are currently under 200
ocean going Jones act compliance ships
nine out of 10 U.S built Jones act
compliance ships
our barges or tugboats
when I said that the oil would need to
go
to a different
nationalities Port after leaving the
United States Port of course that was
assuming that it was not a Joanne Jones
act compliant ships the problem is
there's just not that many of those
ships left
there were some and yes some of them do
offload import and Portsmouth if there
were more there'd be more competition
River
okay you know that well
who was the question representative
Herbert
um this is an interesting conversation
because I didn't I didn't even know what
the Jones Act was but uh I do know that
geopolitically
the cost of energy went up everywhere
yes uh primarily I think because of the
Ukrainian
issue
but if if
um
could we ask or use this information say
for example to requests from the doe or
or maybe even the Biden Administration
that there would be a waiver allowed
so that we could build more ships or or
take our boats and we already export a
lot of oil
and and LNG and everything I don't know
what those ships are but um
because they're going to foreign ports
so that's okay right under the under the
Jones law that doesn't matter that
doesn't matter that would be okay but
think think about the intelligence of
this we're offloading U.S oil putting it
on ships saying you can't deliver this
to a U.S Port we've got to go to a
different country's Port meanwhile those
ships are coming out of Europe and
unloading because those are the only
ones that can do it really other than
the few handful of ships that are Jones
act compliant right it just drives up
the cost of transport transporting the
oil
um
so to answer your first part of the
question uh the idea is yes I mean the
governor did request A Jones act
exemption back the beginning of uh the
winter it was not granted
um but this would be additional
additional uh arrow in his quiver who
did he ask he asked the body
Administration that's they're the only
ones who can do it
well I thought I thought we'd
we can request the waiver but they're
the only ones that can consider it and
Grant it
okay
representative
this may be a would you believe
um but this isn't a partisan issue uh
this putting the Jones act under
scrutiny I'm just going to read a quote
here from uh Chris Pappas who's our one
of our congressman and he said I have
thought about this and I would support a
waiver for the Jones act to make sure
our energy needs are met this winter
there's no reason why if we've got the
resources here in our own country we
shouldn't be using that to fuel our
homes and businesses this winter so
that's something I know the new New
England Governors have called for I
support that as well so our federal
delegation might have a little more
power to
change the current status quo and the
number that you're requesting would you
believe might give him another arrow in
his quiver as well thank you for the
question sir I do believe that
representative
very short
would you believe that the cost for an
oil spill for a ship that does not have
the standards of a U.S manufactured ship
would far outweigh the savings that
I do not believe that a foreign
crude and built vessel would be
immensely more likely to have an oil
follow-up further question Engler
that is not the case
would you believe
without seeing a study that says that or
some sort of information backing it up
no
but thank you for the question
representative Sullivan
yeah thanks for taking my question I'm
just curious what uh it's going to be
the department of energy that's in
charge of figuring this out do you know
like So when you say committee is it
going to have senators and
representatives on it or is it just
they're going to be tasked with figuring
it out and do you know if they have the
appropriate skill set within their
Department to figure that out in a
believable way thank you for the
question there's no committee or
commission that's intended by the
legislation or contemplated by
legislation
um it is the Department of energy you
should all submit a report to the
legislature so there are many qualified
and talented economists that work for
the state and they would be tasked with
coming up with that number which would
be reported to us the assumption is they
wouldn't actually do it they would be
contracting out for someone else to do
it
I'm sure we can tuck that into the
budget
well I just wonder if I can
it was that was my question I was going
I just beat you to it
okay any other questions CNN thank you
very much thank you sir
okay we have uh Griffin Roberts from the
and he takes uh no position he found a
thank you uh Mr chairman uh Griffin
Roberge strategy program manager at the
New Hampshire Department of energy
earlier today or I should say yesterday
uh submitted our written testimony
online via the house uh testimony portal
uh providing paper copies around should
be making their way around the committee
table
um again uh from the Department of
energy we the department is neutral on
this bill as it's amended by the Senate
our letter of testimony provides quite a
bit of background from a very high level
as to the dependency of the region on
natural gas as a source for producing
the uh producing the energy that to meet
our daily demands
um as is outlined in our layer of
testimony in general most of New
England's natural gas arrives via
pipelines New Hampshire's natural gas
utilities unitel and Liberty typically
have firm contracts to receive natural
gas supply from those pipelines and
natural gas electricity generators have
to buy gas from the unused portion of
these get of these pipelines
um which can become quite Limited in the
winter months as I'm sure we're all
aware
straining that available pipeline
capacity can lead to price spikes during
gas system constraints and can lead to
peaking power stations such as Merrimack
station down the road and bow a coal
plant and other oil generators to come
online during those peaking periods to
meet that increasing demand
obviously as I mentioned the region is
heavily dependent on natural gas for its
energy demand a solution to this might
be creating additional pipeline capacity
into the region to meet that growing
demand but as I as I think we're all
aware here citing those pipelines can be
significantly challenging not only in
New Hampshire but in other states where
States establish policies that make it
difficult to cite additional pipeline
infrastructure another way to get
natural gas into the region is through
shipping tankers that carry liquefied
natural gas or LNG
these LNG tankers will typically come
into Boston to help backfill the region
with extra natural gas to meet growing
demand
however as has been mentioned the
Merchant Marine Act of 1920 also known
as the Jones act impedes the ability of
the region to to get to get that
domestically produced liquefied natural
gas by tanker this is what brings us to
the bill here today
um as has been mentioned the Jones act
really is a protectionist federal
statute that requires LNG tankers that
travel between U.S ports to be built
owned and operated or I should say
flagged by Americans and American
companies this means that New England
cannot receive any domestically produced
LNG from places such as Texas or
Pennsylvania by ship in essence the
Jones act precludes all U.S produced LNG
from being delivered to New England
unless it's carried on an American ship
that again is built owned and operated
by Americans and American companies
while the U.S is the largest exporter of
LNG there are no Jones at compliant LNG
tankers that are available
no LNG tankers have been built in the
U.S since roughly the late 1970s into
the 1980s
um
based on the cursory review I think
there's around roughly 12 LNG tankers
that were constructed in U.S ports
between 77 and 80 that could potentially
be reflagged and recrued to become Jones
at compliant however all of those ships
are currently flagged for other
countries
additionally most LNG tankers as has
been mentioned are produced in foreign
countries at cheaper cost they're not
produced here because the costs are
higher
um
this tends to leave New England
dependent on foreign liquefied natural
gas Imports primarily I'm not sure if
anyone on this committee is familiar
with it but there's a little island off
the coast of I believe Venezuela called
the Republic of Trinidad and Tobago
you might not believe it but they're a
very small island but they're one of the
largest LNG producers in the world and
they typically ship most of their stuff
here to the U.S
major geopolitical events as has been
mentioned like Russia's invasion of the
Ukraine have seen LNG tankers being sent
typically to Europe to meet their
growing energy demand because Russia has
suspended its energy exports over to
um over to Europe during this at this
time again these geopolitical events
have caused significant turmoil
um in global energy markets and again as
has been mentioned um in July of last
year New England's Governors including
Governor sununu sent a letter to the U.S
department of energy asking the Biden
Administration to explore suspending the
Jones act for the winter for this past
winter these Governors met with with a
U.S department of energy secretary
Jennifer granholm in September of last
year and while the administration
indicated its continuing approach to
enhance its partnership with the region
no waiver from the Jones act was issued
um
like to turn back a little bit to the
bill I know I've gone off course here
but the bill requires the department of
energy to produce a report to the
legislature on the estimated impact of
the Jones act on New Hampshire's heating
fuel and energy market and the bill
requires the report to be completed by
June 1 of 2024. while the department is
neutral on the bill we would like to see
three amendments to the bill should it
move forward
um the first as is seen in the back of
the last page of my letter of testimony
um
the current bill reads that the
department shall report on the estimated
impact of the Jones act estimated impact
in our opinion is quite broad are we
looking at a social impact an economic
impact a political impact based on at
least all the discussion here today I
believe that the the approach is to get
an economic analysis so we'd suggest
putting the word economic in there to
make that abundantly clear we'd also
appreciate the report date being
extended from June 1 of 2024 to January
1 of 2025 to give us the means to
produce an adequate report and then
finally as I know has been mentioned in
the previous uh testimony the department
would appreciate a 250 000 appropriation
in this bill in order to complete that
report the reason being is that we would
need that appropriation to retain the
services of an outside consultant to
complete this report the department does
not have currently in-house resources
who are overly knowledgeable about the
Jones act and it's specific economic
impacts to the state retaining an
outside consultant with this
appropriation would allow us to have the
means to conduct an in-depth detailed
economic analysis that is New Hampshire
Centric Beyond just a simple literary
review of existing studies resources and
that type of thing that are currently
available which again may not be
specific to New Hampshire and with that
I think obviously in my five minutes on
the pink card I'm done I'll take any
questions
yeah
representative Herbert
uh thank you
the uh
I'm still trying to get my head around
what sounds to me like a very
complicated uh problem but if my my
understanding is under the Jones Act
uh an LNG tanker can go from New Orleans
to
but what happens then is it got to come
back empty sure
just so thank you for the question so
the Jones Act is really an intra ra
national federal statute is that it
requires Goods such as LNG
um that are being shipped between U.S
ports need to be constructed on need to
be ships that are owned operated and
built by Americans and American
companies
um
this pre as I mentioned it precludes any
type of domestically produced LNG uh
that's produced here in America say from
like Texas or Pennsylvania from being
shipped from those areas all the way up
here to Boston and into the region so as
I mentioned the region at those times of
high constraint are dependent on foreign
exports made from to your point say
Spain to Boston to provide that LNG or
in reality Trinidad and Tobago there are
instances where and it's certainly the
case where a lot of the domestically
produced LNG say in Texas or
Pennsylvania are currently being put on
a ship sent to Europe and that can be
done through contracts at those private
companies make and everything like that
but when it comes to accessing
domestically produced LNG and
transporting it by tanker that's where
you trigger the Jones act that's where
those ships fall under the protection of
statue
hopefully that makes sense
it helps representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
our questions I have two related
questions
um
what percentage of the LNG that we use
in our Market is shipped versus piped
that's first question sure that that's a
very good question I don't have that I
don't have that um that data available
now but
doesn't answer your immediate question
but overall the region its dependency on
natural gas the region as a whole
typically depends about 50 of its
overall energy portfolio is staked in
natural gas so again when a region is
highly dependent on one type of fuel for
its energy and then demand grows and
Supply doesn't meet that demand you're
going to see those price spikes that
increase demand and we want to get more
natural gas into the region I can
certainly look into that a little bit
follow-up with the committee but there's
a real specific answers today and
follow-up for the question and this is
just from my own curiosity
natural gas in the winter time
we rely on it to generate electricity
and people also rely on it to heat their
homes
and isn't there a rule if my memory
serves as a rule that says the natural
gas has to be prioritized for heating of
homes over electric generation that's
correct and then when that happens all
their sources have to have to come
online to the coal and the oil that you
mentioned earlier has to fill in that's
correct so typical as you mentioned um
uh what is it a natural gas pipeline
capacity is prioritized for Natural Gas
Utilities like Liberty like unitel who
provide that natural gas for home
heating
um any excess capacity that's available
on those pipelines is bought up by
Electric producers who or I should say
electricity generators who use the
natural gas to produce electricity for
the region when there's not enough
and there's limited again there's
strained pipeline capacity that's where
you get to that point where you have you
start having those price spikes that
limited Supply and that's we have
power plants come online they're
typically that typically only operate
during these peaking periods such as
Merrimack station or oil facilities
around the region that come online to
help meet that growing demand
for the question
and so if I'm understanding this quickly
if there's a constraint in the shipped
Natural Gas
during those Peak periods it forces us
to use more oil and coal to fill in the
representative Gibbs
thank you uh you heard me mention
earlier
um uh someone from the New Hampshire
barge and Tugboat industry
um uh having discussed how oil is
shipped by barges from one U.S port to
another uh in a way that complies with
the Jones Act is this done or could this
be done also for liquefied natural gas
that is could liquefied it is liquefied
natural gas or could liquefied natural
gas also be shipped by barges or does
that have to be shipped by larger
tankers sure and thank you for the
question
um I believe if any type of liquefied
natural gas is to be shipped again
International within within the space of
U.S port to U.S Port it must be Jones
act compliant now could there potential
and I'm certainly not an engineer but
could there potentially be an LNG tanker
that's retrofitted and and to be Jones
act compliant potential but I imagine
that might be cost prohibitive to do so
further question thank you uh sorry that
wasn't my question sure
um okay apparently there are barges
operating now that are
Jones act compliant that ship oil from
one U.S port to another
are there also barges that
are Jones act compliant that ship
liquefied natural gas from one U.S port
to another or if there aren't could
there be is that does that make sense
yeah sure that makes sense so uh are
there
potentially but again we're not
typically seeing that could there be I
could I could say yes but again they
uh sorry can I follow up one more time
last time I promise
okay just for clarification they're
currently
are no such barges or at least hardly
any such bar just for liquefied natural
gas
um but if there were to be some they
would have to be Jones act compliant
um but that could be done it just hasn't
been done yet correct
thank you thank you
so I will let you go but I guess I I
have a question that it affects some of
us that live in Cheshire County
um in which city of Keene actually has
this gas trucked in and uh the story I
heard and then you can tell me where
this is true or not the gas is coming
from the Midwest by Pipeline and makes
it all the way to New York uh just on
the other side of the Hudson River and
then it's loaded up by truck and driven
across this insane route route 9 through
Vermont and delivered to us in Cheshire
county so is that true that that's how
we get our gas uh well thank you for the
question I can't comment specifically on
that but I would say it doesn't broadly
on on the broad end I would say it's not
surprising just because New England as a
region is at the tail end of the
national energy Supply you know we're
not a Texas we're not
um we're not Texas we're not
Pennsylvania where we have abundant
access to natural gas reserves sitting
below our feet
um you know a lot of it needs to be
trucked up here or sent up here and
again when they're isn't that sufficient
pipeline capacity to get it up here
there's going to be other means to do so
such as truck train if there's you know
a ship to do so making sure it's Jones
act compliant if it's shipped between
U.S ports so I would say anecdotally
maybe I but again I just I can't confirm
the the details well the reason I say
that is because even if we were to to
figure out how to get more chips in yet
near us how much will really benefit uh
in in New Hampshire
in particular because we don't have such
a big Port yeah sure to get that access
I always thought Providence was was a
big Port I think I one time used to see
this natural gas tankers pull in there
but I don't even I hear they don't even
do that anymore sure and I mean one the
reason they typically land in in Boston
is because there's a massive electric
generator there called Mystic station
and it is based and it runs on natural
gas so looking for natural gas comes in
goes into the the facility produces
electricity to meet the growing demand
um again during those again we're just
talking about those Peak periods in the
winter where energy demand is at its
highest that's where you start getting
that constraint and available pipeline
currency and yeah that crunch leads to
price spikes because there's growing
demand not not
supplies not meeting that demandation
got it thank you
pillow thank you uh thank you for taking
my question thank you the um are
Renewables
um could Renewables be a part of this
conversation or not because in New
Hampshire we seem to kind of ignore
Renewables as an alternative source of
sure and and thank you for the question
so certainly Renewables are a growing
part I would say
um of the Region's uh fuel mix
um natural you know everything's got to
equal 100 on the pie chart and so if one
goes away something else is going to
take its place
um certainly and these are discussions
we often have frequently in the house st
e committee but you know
um there's a lot of federal money coming
down the pike as well
um to advance renewable energy either
through the inflation reduction act or
the uh infrastructure investment in jobs
act
um I would say yes
simply thanks
okay representative
This concerns excuse me the proposed
amendment to the first one changing the
estimated impact to the estimated
economic impact and that's certainly an
improvement over the word impact which
I'm not sure I know what that means but
equally so economic impact is fairly
broad can you apply on what economic
impact means and what it would involve
studying economic impact sure and thank
you for the question so um I would agree
with you though as as is noted in our in
our testimony the phrase estimated
impact is quite broad having it narrowed
down to the economic impacts from the
Jones act on New Hampshire's uh heating
fuel and energy markets would would
offer the department more specificity
than it was currently in the bill
um I can't opine on specifically
um I'm certainly not an economist right
or by any measure but I imagine the
um if this bill were to go forward with
an appropriation we retain an outside
consultant that study would look at you
know you know maybe episodes in the past
of of uh past periods where energy
demand spiked and prices went along with
it if say more LNG came in by tanker
would there be a requisite uh price drop
or anything like that that's maybe one
aspect that might be looked at in the
report it might also look at
um you know the costs of of not doing
anything regarding this or regarding
um more liquefied natural gas coming in
by tanker that type of thing
for the question
as a follow-up to you think that it
would also look at if for example issues
related to the economic or excuse me the
employment and labor aspects of the oil
and gas industry in New Hampshire or
factors related to the economic impact
of the Jones act and its potential
effects on National Security both in New
Hampshire and New England are those
factors that are within the Department's
capacity to research okay and thank you
again I would submit that we would love
to have an outside consultant into that
um but again you know uh based on at
least testimony we've heard you know I
think the Genesis of the the focus of
the bills to look at economic impact
obviously the legislature can determine
what they want State departments to look
at in various reports if there's further
information that you that this committee
wanted the report to look at certainly
spell that out
um in the in the bill and we'd
appreciate specificity on that
more detail the better yes
great thank you very much thank you uh
chair Recon representative Yuri polzo
foreign
[Music]
I was very excited when Senator Murphy
submitted this bill as you heard in this
testimony all our constituents paying
higher prices for energy and it's uh
important to investigate this I see it's
John's act as it is
very insulting to our middle time
industry because our other Industries
are competing in some way like in Auto
Auto industry Ford and Tesla produced in
the US successfully compete with
vehicles for example produced in Mexico
in Aerospace
and competes with European
producers of Civilian aircrafts and so
on so I'm totally optimistic
optimistic that our Maritime industry
can and should be able to compete with
14 vessels
and uh
I agree with a line of questioning that
the representatives peer was doing about
non-bought States yeah yes there could
be other ways to lower energy in New
Hampshire for example building pipelines
or energy corridors from Canada but if
you was here long enough you know that
it's politically almost impossible to
build a pipelines through New Hampshire
or analogical door so here so uh
shipping to Boston area of energy is
crucial for us and for
all the citizens we need to
get to the data to estimate this
economic impact so our governor and our
U.S debt representative Chris papas
would have solid data to fight for our
constituents and to lower energy prices
here please support this Bill thank you
great thank you
see no questions
got one more Kyle a card left to Kyle
Burleson
representing
and
American Waste ways operators but
ully
um
explain why my testimony I uploaded onto
that portal so you all have access to it
along with footnotes where I said where
I get
Jones act has been repeated here in the
United States law regarding the cargo
I'm sorry thank you
Jones act as United States law requiring
cargo move between U.S ports be
transported on vessels owned by U.S
companies built in U.S shipyards accrued
by U.S Mariners the men and women of the
U.S Towing industry who we represent
comprise the largest segment of the 40
000 vessel strong Jones act Fleet that's
40 000 vessels not the couple hundred
that I heard earlier they play a vital
role in the nation supply chain whereas
SB 102 portrays the Jones act as small
and insubstantial and Truth the U.S
Maritime industry supports more than 650
000 people and contributes more than 150
billion dollars annually in economic
input in New Hampshire alone the
maritime industry contributes over 230
million dollars annually to the state
economy provides good family wage jobs
for New Hampshire residents the United
States domestic Maritime Fleet and
international carriers work in tandem to
provide timely fuel delivery in New
Hampshire in 2022 the port of Portsmouth
saw 96 vessel deliveries of home heating
oil and other important fuel products
amounting to about two vessels per week
totaling millions of barrels of fuel for
New Hampshire residents however owing
largely to New Hampshire's proximity to
Canada around two-thirds of New
Hampshire's fuel deliveries are sourced
in St John's New Brunswick and carried
on International or non-jones act
vessels well U.S vessel operators have a
healthy presence of Portsmouth
delivering Fuel and conducting ship
Assist work and building more vessels in
New England shipyards to support the
market it is erroneous to direct
concerns over the cost of home heating
oil towards the Jones act when
two-thirds of New Hampshire's fuel
shipments are made on International
vessels
indeed the bill references waivers to
the Jones act as a way to decrease fuel
costs
while it does that the cost of shipping
has virtually no impact on the cost of
fuel the consumers fuel prices on the
World Market are determined by oil
companies and energy Traders and any
transportation savings pocketed by those
energy Traders we've seen this wherever
Jones act waivers are issued
in short when the Jones Act is waived as
oil Traders not consumers and certainly
not American Mariners who benefit
Jones act has broad support across the
political Spectrum as well as across the
United States ensuring that Americans
serve Americans helps both workers and
businesses but the Jones act also serves
the United States another important
respect National Security General
Jacqueline Von Ovis commander of U.S
Transportation command testified
recently in a house armed services
Committee hearing the Jones act along
with other federal laws and policies
ensure we have the necessary U.S flag
capability and U.S Mariners during
peacetime and are ready to move
sensitive defense materials during a
national emergency
in 2020 a bipartisan group of national
lawmakers described the Jones act as an
important asset to our military noting
that U.S crude vessels around the world
expand our military's Horizon by serving
as the eyes and ears of our nation
and in keeping our military well
supplied
losing the Jones act They concluded
would hurt our ability to project power
during a time of War National Emergency
and this is no less true for New
Hampshire Port of Portsmouth is one of
the Navy's most important operational
areas in the country in the Jones act
ensures the Navy can Charter American
vessels with American Mariners both
regulated by the U.S Coast Guard to
assist with its operations the
importance of the Jones act and National
Security is further highlighted by
recent stories regarding the possible
use of Chinese manufactured Harbor
cranes by the Chinese Communist party to
gather information about American ports
some of our most critical pieces of
infrastructure weakening the Jones act
would go beyond that along foreign
Nationals to move products including
Dangerous Ones such as petroleum
products and fertilizer throughout our
nation's extensive Coastal and inland
waterways this is just one reason the
Jones act has such strong support from
our military
aw member and partner companies are
proud to serve the people of New
Hampshire as a front line industry to
its energy supply chain and reaching
studies on the economic impact of the
Jones act has affirmed its importance to
the nation
for instance in 2013 the government
accountability office found that the
Jones act helped ensure reliable regular
service to the United States and Puerto
Rico and concluded this service was
important to the economy there in 2020 a
Boston hawaii-based economists released
a study find the Jones acted no
significant impact on the cost of living
in Hawaii most recently in 2022 and I
think you have a handout showing this as
gas prices were peaking a study found
that the Jones act contributed less than
one cent to the overall cost of gasoline
per gallon
the Jones act has stood up to all
rational assessment and we believe that
a study that assesses its impact
specifically in New Hampshire would
arrive at the same general conclusions
we've seen in these previous studies
it'll cost the state tens of thousands
of dollars an Untold amount of time and
ignore real drivers for increased
heating fuel costs and it also gives
some extreme interest groups the
opportunity to exploit the mere
existence of such a study to create the
perception of mounting opposition to the
Jones act for these reasons we urge the
committee to vote against this bill our
members remain committed to working with
the government of New Hampshire the
people of New Hampshire to work on your
energy issues and I want to I want to
offer that on behalf of our members
today but it takes it takes everybody it
takes the carriers it takes the oil
companies it takes takes you all uh I
really appreciate your time and
consideration I'm happy to answer any
questions
okay
I can't ask a real question because I
never got an answer to my first question
as to why Anon Jones Act
oil uh heating oil uh facility doesn't
charge anymore than a jones-act ship of
heating oil to New Hampshire
I didn't get an answer for why there's
no difference between those two so I
gave up
you want to try to answer that question
I mean one thing I'll add is that
foreign carriers uh obviously they're
not regulated by the Coast Guard
um they pay their Sailors uh just enough
to avoid being accused of slavery
uh and obviously the construction
standards aren't there
um you know the Chinese government
subsidizes shipbuilding to the tune of
you know hundreds of billions of dollars
um so without subsidizing our
shipbuilding industry of course we're
not going to build ships any cheaper I
can tell you that we have several member
companies and there's several companies
that aren't members of organization that
would love to get involved in the liquid
natural gas business however uh they're
not going to do that without a contract
that ensures that they'll be able to
pay off for that investment ships are
expensive granted the the technology to
liquefy natural gas and to handle things
under pressure is expensive no matter
where you build it the real problem in
New England is that these products are
generally purchased on the spot Market
when you're completely subject to Global
supply and demand as it has already been
referenced
um
purchasing on a contract would stabilize
prices it would give the shipping
companies the security they need to
engage in these things as I mentioned we
have member companies
such as Crowley which already serves
this area we have a non-member company
named Brian our transportation that
serves this area considerably shell and
Harvey Golf are also interested in this
as well
um
I know that didn't fully answer your
question but it's something our industry
is very interested in and would love to
have a further conversation with uh
policymakers about it
for the question we inquire
I do have a question I figured one out I
found another note
I saw that at the end of last year uh
Matson shipping
uh
I guess signed a contract with
Philadelphia Shipyard the three of the
largest container tank ships
ever built in the United States worth
over a billion dollars and they should
have them finished in about two years or
three years
but my question is this
they don't want to ship oil they don't
want to ship uh natural gas to New
England they want to ship it going east
going west rather they want to ship to
China
and
out in that direction I guess they want
to ship it overseas in other words so my
it seems like everywhere I've looked
selling Natural Gas
to New England doesn't seem to be a
priority to almost any shipping outfit
that they can get more money per
BTU if you will from almost anybody else
is that an observation that's valid
I mean that's that's the Dynamics of a
global market if somebody is willing to
pay more that's where the material is
going to go uh one thing I can tell you
is some of our member companies that
serve New Hampshire have noted that a
lot of the vessels they bring here
aren't fully loaded which suggests that
the needs being met
um
I'm not familiar with the the Matson
ships you're referencing you know we
deal exclusively with tugboats towboats
barges we do have a relationship with
some of the folks at Matson so I'm happy
to follow up with that on you it might
also be that they're serving Hawaii
because Matson does a tremendous amount
okay
representative
thank you thank you for taking our
question New Hampshire is a really nice
State it'd be a shame if something
happened to it so I appreciate if uh you
know you're testifying before us today
um
in the Department's letter it talks
about uh l d tankers and it says there
are currently 12
LNG tankers
that were constructed that would meet
the Jones act but they're being
re-flagged in other countries
is it true that there aren't any LNG
compliant tankers and what would it take
to get one or two of these vessels
reflagged in the U.S so it would be
compliant sure
um I can't speak specifically to tankers
because that's not who we represent we
represent tugboats and barges I do know
that we have members very interested in
converting barges into carrying LNG but
again the cost of that needs means they
need a long-term contract to help
justify their investment uh re-flagging
a vessel is possible although it is
difficult I believe it requires an act
of Congress but it has happened before
you know and that would be more it's a
lot more likely that's a ship that was
built in America was a Jones act vessel
left the service and came back it's
going to be a lot harder politically to
Reef to to flag a vessel United States
that wasn't built in the United States
um
representative Gibbs thank you
you said that it would be possible uh to
convert
um some of the barges uh that are
currently operating uh in and out of U.S
ports to ship liquefied natural gas did
I understand you correctly that the
issues are not really technological but
rather matters of costs yes ma'am
okay thank you very much thank you so
are you the barges that I see in
Pittsburgh that push all the coal up